You guys couldn't hear the music!
Why
does this go so hard?
Why does this go so hard?
Viewers in the chat are expressing frustration.
That's the AI message.
I got you.
Thanks, Viper!
Oh my god.
My voice is not very warmed up today yet.
Sorry.
I'm just drinking my first tea also.
Did you make this game?
I might as well, right?
Oh
god.
Sorry, I'm like so... If you don't know, this company is called Curate, right?
And they make every single...
one of my favorite games ever.
If you know the Bunny Girl...
I have to turn it down just a little bit.
If you know the Bunny Girl cafe game...
Oh, what was it called?
Bunny Garden?
They made that too.
They made Bunny Garden.
So, you know, sometimes their games kind of blow up.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
They made Bunny Garden?
Uh-huh.
But this one is like a vampire-survivor-type game.
So I'm very excited.
Kaiten-zushi!
Wait.
So this is Akiba Station, right?
This Kaiten-zushi place, this rotating sushi place is actually...
It's not there anymore.
It's been... It's gone now, unfortunately.
Is this a spicy game then?
Yes.
Can you put yourself at the end of the maid lineup?
Like down here?
I'm in the game!
Oh wait.
There we... Wait.
I'm covering the logo though.
Not as spicy as Bunny Garden or the Days games.
This one?
I think this one is pretty spicy still though.
I don't think Bunny Garden was that spicy.
From what I saw of it.
But I think...
They didn't have a green maid.
So true!
I think this one has some good spice.
I think this one has some good spice in it.
But Bunny Garden...
Besides like the panty shot, sometimes it wasn't that bad.
But...
But curate games can get pretty...
I think that's also why it blew up a little bit.
You know?
It was more friendly for other people to play.
The mainstream masses, maybe.
But no.
I'm a freak.
I wanna play.
The edgier the better.
Yeah, more YouTube accessible.
Yeah, yeah.
The edgier the better.
I don't know so much about this game.
I've been wanting to play it since the day I saw that it was announced, though.
I was just like, this game is made for me!
I thought about you when I saw this game.
Thank you for thinking about me.
Also, the same company made Trouble Days, which also went kind of viral.
Oh,
and also the hotel, Izanami Hotel.
They make such a wide variety, which I really like.
And they're always kind of changing the kind of gameplay, so I appreciate that, too.
Livestream.
I love edgy games!
But this one is about maids.
It takes place in Akihabara.
And I actually really like Vampire Survivor-type games.
I haven't played Vampire Survivors...
Am I tilted?
Can't tell.
Anyway, I haven't played Vampire Survivors itself, but I've played Vampire Survivor-type games.
I really like them, so...
Eye Tracker!
Oh!
I can't do the Eye Tracker!
No!
My setup for it is on the other monitor.
I can't.
Oh, no!
Thank you, Mint!
Excited to watch this.
Yippee!
Thanks for the iron cyber!
Thank you!
Dang.
Maybe if I play it again...
I just got here.
What is this?
What is this game?
Well, it's a Vampire Survivor-type game with edgy maids.
And some visual novel aspect.
No Eye Tracker needed... right now.
Let's just get into it, though.
It happened suddenly, without warning.
I don't have time to understand what's going on.
There wasn't even enough time to try and comprehend what was going on.
But I just found out that there were a lot of people who suddenly lost their minds and started attacking other people.
The only thing that was certain was that some people had lost their minds and started attacking others.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why my voice is very weird today.
My everyday life is always sounding and falling apart.
I can't help it.
All we could do was just run away.
As our peaceful lives started to slowly crumble around us, all we could do was run.
It's weird.
Yeah, my voice is really rough for you.
I think because... well, I didn't just wake up.
Oh my god!
Look at the...
Wait, I'm blocking.
Look at the guy I'm blocking.
And this guy over here...
He has like the pen lights and everything.
Those do not look like normal pen lights though.
Those look like...
Traff... or like plain traffic lights.
Akihabura.
Yes, Akihabura.
Look, we have games instead of gamers.
Gaox.
So funny.
The maid even.
So cute.
But the pachinko and slot stays there, baby.
Oh!
Hobby paradise.
Hulks instead of Valks.
Vulks, I mean.
Sorry.
This way is no good too.
There seems to be a lot of zombie looking things here as well.
You should not give up Rinka!
There might be other ways to escape!
We can't give up Rinka.
There has to be an escape route somewhere.
I know.
Yeah, I know.
But then we'll have to go outside if we are left out with the zombies.
We can go and stay inside a building.
We can't stay outside like this.
We'll be hunted down in no time.
Maybe it would be better to seek shelter in a building or something.
Nagisa, would you like to walk?
Vulks wagon?
Nagisa, can you walk?
You know that I'm tougher than I look.
I'm just twisting my ankle a little.
I'll be fine.
She's been bit.
I think Nagisa's the type to be bit and then... I just met her, but I think she's the type to be bit and not tell anybody.
Then let's go.
Nagisa's gonna die.
No, we won't let any of our precious maids die.
Oh, their maid outfits are so cute.
I like the ribbons.
They're like cross ribbons on this one.
Oh, you can't see.
This seems like a good place to hide for now, yeah?
Oh my god, we're at Toli's!
I mean... Oli's?
Have you played any of the Akiba's Trip games?
I've heard...
I've also heard of the anime... Also, have you heard of the anime ZOM100?
I have heard of the anime ZOM100, but I have not watched it.
And yes, I've played Akiba's Trip.
I have.
She's already turning.
Looks good.
Just gonna close my eyes and rest for a bit.
Oh god, Nagisa!
Oh my god, she's about to die for real.
Oh, Nagisa.
Uh oh.
Nagisa?
I'm fine.
She's bitten for sure?
Oh god.
I'm fine, really.
I don't look fine at all.
I just sprained my ankle.
I don't know why I look so pale.
You're not fine at all.
There's no way this is from a sprained ankle.
I'm fine.
I just ran while holding my ankle.
I'm just a little tired.
Trust me, I'm okay.
Just a little tired from having to compensate for my ankle.
That's all.
That's fine.
If you're sure... Oh god, Rinka, run!
Run!
It looks like it's going to be hard for me to run and escape like this.
They're moving faster than I thought.
Oh no.
Either way, it might be a bit difficult to continue and try to outrun them.
They're quicker than they look.
You're right.
I don't think I have the confidence to run away like this.
And I don't really have the confidence with this leg of mine.
In the first place, what do you think that zombie is?
What do you think that zombie is?
Actually, it was all a movie shoot.
What do you think that zombie -like things are anyway?
You don't think we got trapped on a movie set or something, do you?
Wasn't that a TV show?
Like a Korean TV show?
Where they had people sign up and think that they were going on a different type of reality show.
And then they actually instead...
It was supposed to be like a zombie apocalypse happened.
That feels very illegal.
I'm in.
I can't wait to finally meet you at OTAC.
OTAC.
I'll come to the meet and greet cosplay with you as you are the twist.
I hope you can accept gifts.
I made a cute skirt and hair bow.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited to see.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited to see.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited to see.
Sounds familiar.
I think it was that.
Right, Tao?
Oh my gosh, instead of it was a...
But I think it had to be very obviously like...
It's not a real zombie apocalypse.
Or else you'd really panic.
But you know.
The green maid in the bottom right is defo a freak.
What do you think those zombie-like things are anyway?
You don't think we got... Oh, movies chat.
That's right.
People wouldn't be dying on a movie set.
Besides, Akihabara is in total chaos.
I guess you have a point.
A guitarist is shredding.
Right!
All we know is that being bitten by one of them will also turn you into a zombie!
Before we know it, Akihabara could be filled with zombies!
I hope everyone at the maid cafe was able to make it out okay.
This is the sequel to Akihabara Maid Wars, everybody.
Who knows?
I mean, we were out handing flyers, so it's hard to say what happened.
All we can do is pray.
I actually got my pants up in this game.
Crazy.
It's only a matter of time before they make it here too.
We need to find a safe place to take shelter.
Hey, Rinko-chan.
Leave me here.
Rinko, it's okay to leave me behind!
Don't tell me you're kidding me at a time like this.
Now's not the time for jokes.
I can't run away with these legs.
But Rinko-chan can run.
You know that I won't be able to run with this leg of mine, but you can, right?
She just doesn't want to tell her that she's been bit.
But she's definitely been bit.
She doesn't want to tell her that she's been bit.
She just wants to lessen the guilt.
Bustin', bustin', bustin'.
I'm not trying to be a hero or anything.
I just think it'd be better for you to go on ahead.
A-aheyed.
To look for help for the both of us.
No.
I can't do that.
Why not?
You know deep down it's the right thing to do.
I'm just gonna drag you down like this.
Why not?
You know deep down it's the right thing to do.
I'm just gonna drag you down like this.
Splitting up for a bit is what's best for the both of us.
Also, let me know if the audio is okay.
I've been trying to have it not be so loud, but also so you can make sure you hear it.
Whoever gets to be a sub, thank you.
Thank you for the Super Chat boost!
Thank you!
Two EU-friendly streams in a week?
Am I losing it?
Hello!
There's no other option, Nagisa.
Look here?
Uh-oh.
Did Rinka get bit?
Wait!
We were wrong!
Nice!
What a twist!
Rinka!
Wait, when did...
How did this happen?
How did you not...
How did you not notice this?
Sorry,
I'm trying not to be a censor, you know?
Just get me off the screen.
Here, here, here.
Um...
Everybody, take your peek.
Get your sneak peek.
Get your little...
Get your little fill.
I don't know how her skirt's doing that, to be honest.
But...
Thank you, Minto.
You're welcome.
I think I was bitten earlier while running away.
I can feel myself starting to lose control!
No way!
If that happens, I might attack you.
Soon enough, I'll lose control and become just like those zombies.
There's a big chance I'll attack you, too!
That's why...
I'll say goodbye here.
I'll lure as many zombies as I can and go far away.
This is where I say goodbye.
I'll do my best to lure them far away from here.
If you press it, if you click on it...
Nothing happens.
You don't need to do that!
If you go far away, I'll get you healed!
Wait, I did say Rinka's line, right?
She's gonna run away and lure them away?
You don't need to do that!
Rinka...
Sorry, Nagisa.
Live.
Even if it's just you.
Wouldn't it be so funny if Nagisa went like, Wouldn't it be so funny if Nagisa went like, But Rinka!
and then showed her her bite, too, and was just like, Bite me, Rinka!
Bite me, Rinka!
Down, boy, down!
You just met her.
Promise me you'll live.
For my sake, too.
Oh!
Spaghetti!
Wait, please!
Rinka-chan!
Oh, no!
The usual daily life sounds and collapses.
I watched as my life crumbled around me.
All I could do was reach my hand out to Rinka's back as it slipped further and further away from me.
Oh!
Rinka-chan?
When she was happy and healthy and not a zombie.
Wait, are we gonna see her, like, transform?
I'm so glad!
You're all right!
Rinka-chan?
Wait a minute!
Where are you going?
She's dreaming about her.
I'm begging you!
Oh!
Stop, this looks just like Crepscule maid cafe.
Oh, is everything okay then?
It was a dream?
It looks like she woke up.
You're finally awake.
It seems.
Oh!
Cute!
Oh my gosh, she's so cute!
She's so cute!
Oh my god, stop.
I swear, the art keeps getting better and better in these games.
Color?
Mint color!
This game was made for me!
Who are you?
How did I end up in such a place?
You seem a little confused.
Being caught up in such a pandemic makes it more difficult to stay in a good mood.
Seems like you're a bit confused.
But I guess that's to be expected after being involved in such a pandemic.
I'd be surprised if you weren't.
Pandemic?
A pandemic?
I'm Kanon Mikagami.
I was thinking of using this cafe as a base, but you fell down in the store, so I had to protect you.
I thought this shop would be a good place to hide, but you seem to have found it first.
I patched you up a bit.
Pandemic?
I think this is more like an epidemic.
I think we're in big trouble.
A shop?
Oh, right.
You mean this mint cafe.
This is the maid cafe where Rinka and I used to work.
Rinka and I used to work here, actually.
After I broke up with Rinka, I'll be back here again.
I'll be back here again.
Pandemic is bigger than an epidemic though?
Is it actually?
Wait, I always thought that it was the opposite.
I thought epidemic was the worst one.
I'd call it an apocalypse.
Oh, epidemic is more small...
Oh...
I thought pa...pani...
Oh, everything.
Epidemic, I think to me it just sounds like epicdemic.
So it's...
So in my brain, I'm just like...
It's epically bad.
So that's why I always thought that it was worse than pandemic.
Kind of makes sense.
Though it doesn't.
An epicdemic.
I guess after splitting with Rinka, I ran all the way out here without realizing...
What if she's...
What if Rinka is immune, you know?
Luckily there were no zombies around, so I took the time to set some precautions up.
I've decided to use this place as my base.
The SSR Demic.
This is from the livestream devs.
Yep, yep, yep.
Spent the whole day setting up the fence and doing some maintenance.
It should be worth it to keep the zombies away.
It's different from the usual maid cafe.
W-Wait a minute!
Did you say it was the first day?
Yanwei, thank you!
Easy to remember.
Pan, like pansexual.
Thank you.
Freaky Demic.
Seems like a majority of survivors are people who don't wear pants.
True!
I wonder if there's a lot of survivors in Scotland.
You're right, it does look a bit different.
Wait, you said you did all of this in one day?
Yes.
To be more precise, I found you.
28 hours and 32 minutes have passed since I found you.
How long were you asleep?
To be exact, it took 28 hours and 32 minutes after finding you and patching you up.
That long?
What happened to Akihabara since then?
I've been out that long?
What happened to Akihabara?
Uh oh.
It's better not to go outside.
The number of zombies that appeared in Akihabara is still increasing.
I wouldn't go out there if I were you.
The number of zombies keeps going up.
Then I can't just sit around and do nothing.
That's more of a reason to go out there and do something.
I might still be out there!
I need to go help her!
Rinko, my friend might still be out there!
I need to go save her!
I can't do anything on my own.
Mr. Nagisa Hihara.
Oh, how does she know my name?
I can't have you going off on your own, Ms. Nagisa Hihara.
Did I tell you my name?
Your student ID was in your pocket.
Oh, she's a freak.
Why were you trying... she was trying to rob me!
She pickpocketed me.
The sleeves... I know Kanon is so cute.
You won't be leaving here.
I can't have you go out there only to be turned into a zombie once you do.
Why are Kanon's hands like that?
Why are you so rude?
You're an all too important test subject for us.
One that's carrying a very specific antibody.
Oh my god, she already.
She did experiments on me in my sleep.
Sample?
I'm a test subject?
Yes.
I am a very valuable sample.
Mr. Nagisa, what do you think about the appearance of zombies?
Yes.
A very rare one at bat.
Why do you think those zombies suddenly appeared, Ms. Nagisa?
Well, it's common in movies.
So she did get bitten, right?
That's what it sounds like, right?
What are we?
Umbrella corporation?
If we're going by movie logic, maybe an unknown virus spread from one person to the next, or something.
You got it.
It's believed... Sorry.
It's believed that the reason these zombies appeared in Akihabara is because of a pandemic causing virus.
From what we know so far, the only way for this virus to spread is through bodily fluid from zombie to person.
So this is the reason, right?
Ah, well...
Bodily fluid.
That's why zombie bites are so deadly.
If there's saliva or blood enters your system, it's game over.
Rinka!
Oh, the panty shot.
Are we gonna smooch some zombies?
In a few hours, they'll spawn and turn into zombies.
From my observations, it seems most infected humans will transform instantly.
Though the latest is a couple of hours, so Rinka...
Rinka started to turn pretty quickly, she said.
She was starting to lose control.
So we did get bit.
A few individuals carry a special antibody.
Oh my gosh, maybe I should've made coffee instead of tea.
It seems like you're one of those people, Miss Nagisa.
W-w-w-w-wait
a second!
Antibodies?
As in the things that protect you from getting colds?
Yes.
In conclusion, you are already infected.
W-w-w-w-wait!
Precisely.
This might be a bit frank, but you've already been infected!
Probably, when you're running away from zombies, you'll be bitten before you know it.
We knew it!
More than likely, you were bit at some point when running away.
The Ulmer Reismaner.
But for some reason, your body hasn't reacted.
You're completely symptom-free, which means you must have that antibody.
Does that mean we can make an antidote with this antibody of mine?
That's exactly what I've been researching here.
Oh my god.
What a perfect research location.
Kiss your friend to cure.
I've made a vaccine prototype from your blood.
Oh my god, she's already taken my blood and everything!
But it'll still need to undergo some more modifications and tests.
Amazing!
With that vaccine, I can make a zombie!
Waku-chin.
Oh gosh, I learned that word in 2020.
That's vaccine.
That's amazing!
With such a vaccine, we'd be able to turn zombies back into humans, right?
No, it's not that useful.
Even if you've become a complete zombie, you won't be able to save yourself.
Waku-chin.
Waku-waku-chin-chin.
Yeah, waku-waku-chin-chin.
Sadly, no.
Even if we administered the vaccine to someone who was fully turned, they wouldn't be able to revert back.
Those who have been infected, but have not yet been infected...
Waku-waku-chin-chin!
Or those who have not been infected, the main purpose is to prevent them.
But it could be used to prevent full transformations of people who've been bitten or prevent someone from becoming infected.
Besides, this is nothing more than a prototype.
In a place like this, we can't develop a proper vaccine.
We haven't done any clinical trials, and we don't know if it's really effective.
Their major... they... they... they are...
They are... they are...
They are... there are major limitations when working somewhere like this.
I haven't even been able to test it.
So I don't even know how effective it is.
They are... they are...
I don't care.
Even if it was only a 1% chance, I'd still take the gamble.
What are you saying?
I told you, a friend of mine is still outside.
Oh, gosh.
A friend of hers, you guys.
A friend of hers.
She was bitten, but this vaccine might be able to save her if she hasn't fully transformed.
Were you listening?
There's no guarantee that this vaccine will work.
Yeah, but Kanon, weren't you listening?
Were you even listening to what I said?
No one knows how effective this vaccine is.
And Nagisa said that she would take the 1% chance.
Well, that friend of hers...
It was Rinka.
She's been bitten for at least 28 hours.
And your friend, Rinka, wasn't it?
Well, it's been at least 28 hours since she was bitten.
It's normal to think that she's already become a zombie.
She's more than likely...
As long as it doesn't happen, there's nothing we can do to save her.
Hmm...
Oh, she's more than likely turned into a zombie by now.
A miracle would have to happen to save her.
She has those crazy eyes.
Nagisa looks crazy right now.
She's like...
And I told you, didn't I?
It doesn't matter.
Even if it's a 1% chance, I'd do anything for my friend.
Seems like you won't listen to reason.
I'll help you find Rinka.
If you're going to be that way, then I'll be...
I'll be helping look for Ms. Rinka to...
Nino?
Are you sure?
Even if I can convince her here, she'll sneak out her vaccine.
Even if I ended up convincing you, I'm sure you'd still sneak off with the vaccine anyway.
Okay, okay.
I think we need to be a little bit more like practical about this, right?
Like this...
This might be the only person that we know of that...
has an antibody to this virus.
And we're just going to let her go?
We're not going to...
We need to take like notes.
We need to...
We need to document our research in case somebody does find this and is able to then see everything and create a cure.
We need to take ample, ample amounts of her blood, you know?
To like have it as extra so that it can be continued research.
We need Rinka.
If you're going to do that, you need to prepare a weapon first.
A weapon!
I'm sorry, but please take that with you.
That's one of my favorite Japanese words.
A weapon.
If we're going outside, we'll have to prepare some weapons.
They're makeshift, but we don't have much of a choice.
Please take this.
That's...
Wait, but that's...
A gun!
It's an assault rifle.
It's an assault rifle?
You've seen it in movies, right?
I'm sure you've seen one in a movie or something.
Totally makeshift assault rifle.
It's real?
Not just like some toy?
I'd be arrested for carrying this.
Martial law.
Obviously, the police have been infected too.
Now's not the time to worry about laws.
Please learn how to defend yourself with it.
You made a vaccine?
And you even have this weapon?
Really?
You made a vaccine?
And collected weapons?
Kanon, who exactly are you?
I can't move from here to make a vaccine, but...
It's pink.
It's so cute.
If you need anything, please contact me through the mobile phone.
Oh, her trigger discipline though.
Oh, she does...
Never mind.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I thought that...
Never mind.
I made...
It was...
Oh, it was hidden by the bar.
That's why.
Wow.
Okay.
Glasses girl is still...
Glasses girls are cute.
So true.
Thank God.
I can't leave here as I'll be working on the vaccine, but please contact me using this communicator if you need me.
My codec frequency is...
Please don't make me do anything stupid.
Please don't be reckless.
You're one in a million after all.
Y-Yes...
Okay.
Anyway, I have to go help Rinka.
I should think of other things after that.
For starters, I need to rescue Rinka.
I can think about the rest after that.
Oh, tutorial time.
The main objective of any stage is to clear it while staying away from danger.
However, each stage will have a different feeling.
Additional Conditions.
Oh, oh.
Your equipped gun will automatically shoot.
Oh, okay.
The trajectory can be changed to shoot behind by pressing LB.
LB?
Like on my mouse?
You can lock on your shooting...
Oh, by pressing LB, you can lock on your shooting trajectory separate to your movement.
You can switch between lock on by holding down or lock on toggle in the options.
Is this made Vampire Survivors?
Yes, actually.
Oh!
By pressing...
Wait, should this be played with a controller?
Uh-oh.
Close-range attack?
You can attack with a close-range weapon in your arsenal.
Weapons can only be used after the weapon gauge fills up.
I play mouse plus keyboard?
Oh, wait.
Choosing a skill.
Collecting powers that enemies drop will increase your level.
You can gain new skills by choosing them when you level up.
Oh, okay.
Let's see what we got.
Grenade...
Landmine...
Special.
If the same skill is selected, its skill level will increase.
The level cap differs based on each skill.
Some skills do not level up.
The number of skills that can increase in battle are limited.
Some skills allow additional effects on selected skills.
Choose the right skills for the right situation.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Support attack drone.
Now it's a burst fire gun.
HP auto heals.
Wait, but I'm not hurt.
Increase defense by 9%.
Increase movement by 5%.
Attack...
This sounds nice, though.
The drone.
Have some health.
Look at him.
He's going.
He's going for it.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, nice.
More drone.
The increase is cool down.
Oh, nice.
More drone.
No way.
More drones.
Oh my god.
I don't want to have to do any work.
I think you guys know the deal.
More drones!
Oh, power increase.
Okay.
Increases drone strength!
Increases... oh wait.
Increases drone strength by 50%.
Never mind.
More drone!
Oh, hell yeah.
I'm so slow, it's painful.
Okay, next thing.
If I can increase my speed...
I will do so.
I'm so slow.
Increases maximum HP.
This game looks cute, right?
Drone-chan, my beloved.
Well, we have no more drones.
Wait!
Decreases...
Let's do...
Let's do the attack cooldown.
Die, zombie!
Look at the little otaku!
Otaku chomen!
As your fellow otaku, I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I can't tell where...
Where my other drones are attacking.
Oh my gosh, there's so many zombies over here.
Oh, I'm...
Is there a place I'm supposed to be going?
I think I just last... I think I just survive.
Right?
Oh!
Oh, there's so many!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
More drones!
Wait, a drone that circles...
the area while shooting...
lightning!
I think we need...
some more drones.
Electric drone!
That's technically another drone.
So...
Technically it's own drone.
Nice.
Drone flight time.
Let's do optimize.
Sorry, drones.
Oh!
Okay, that was a fun little tutorial level.
SRank.
She hates drones.
No!
Oh my god!
This is where big camera is.
I know exactly where this is.
This corner.
And then if you turn around, that's where the sign...
like over on this side is the sign with the...
like the famous at home sign...
and everything.
Yeah, I know exactly where we are.
Yeah,
I know exactly where we are.
Thank you.
Hi-to-sation.
Is that Taito?
It is!
This is where those horrible...
Those guys are at.
Blip.
Remember the basics of CQC or just use...
more drones!
Wait a sec.
Don't just throw me into a horde of zombies!
This is what you wanted, isn't it?
I don't even know how to use a drone!
I've never even trained in a battle like this before!
I still don't know how to use a gun!
Nor have I ever trained in any type of combat!
That's why we just use drones!
It's okay.
Thanks to the virus...
Nagisa's physical abilities...
are way better than normal people's.
She's a super human!
Oh my gosh!
Thanks to the virus, you've become a lot stronger than the average person.
Eh?
Not the codec.
With the international sports competition...
you can win all the gold medals.
Get off!
Thanks for three months!
You can be a champion...
A genome soldier?
No!
Neuromachines?
Oh yeah.
I also...
I made the blood purple.
So if you see the purple on the ground...
I thought it would be kinda cute.
What are the zombies doing that they're blowing up the top of buildings?
If you were to enter any international sports competition right now...
You'd have to win gold.
The Olympics are happening right now.
Even stronger than those military personnel over there.
That strong?
I'm not that strong...
I'm that strong?
I don't really feel any different.
But her strength does not equate to her knowing how to use a gun.
Purple blood?
What is this?
Maid girl Danganronpa?
Yes.
Thanks for three months, Sasha!
Thank you for the EU-friendly stream.
Of course!
I mean, you completely swept away that horde of zombies, right?
Not many people could do that by themselves.
And it's not just your strength, either.
Your ability to recover has also become superhuman.
You're right.
The scars I got from the zombies are all gone.
Oh my god.
Because I got infected with the virus...
She's insane!
Not only you mentioned it, all the scratches from earlier have completely healed!
This is all because I was infected with the virus?
To be precise, the virus gives you unlimited ammo.
The virus gives you unlimited ammo.
That's what I should say.
Well, to be technical, it's because you've been spared from the negative effects of the virus using that special antibody inside of you.
However, it's only because I recovered so quickly that I've become stronger.
If I get cut off, I won't be able to return to normal.
So please be careful.
But please remember, all your body is doing is healing faster.
Regrowing limbs is impossible even at your current state.
So please be careful.
Aw man, I thought I was a lizard.
You're too scary, Kano-chan!
Please make me feel at ease!
You have my current state?
What the heck?
I don't want to think about that!
How about you try and be a bit more comforting?
If I don't get surrounded by zombies, I can do something.
Please look around.
Sorry for the blip.
Obvious.
If you were entering a sporting competition, you would win gold because everyone else is dead.
Maybe the virus is a way to find super soldiers for the evil organization behind this.
You have a point there.
You'll be fine as long as those zombies don't completely surround you.
Please always watch your back and make sure you have an escape rope.
Like I said earlier, Nagisa-san is a valuable sample.
If I lose you, I won't be able to develop a vaccine.
Go face when you'll never be a lizard, babe.
My dreams are crushed.
I told you before, but you're one in a million sample.
If we lose you, we may never be able to make a vaccine to counter this.
Okay.
The maid cafe has maintained its function as a base.
Of course, we have to speed up, but we can also maintain and strengthen our equipment.
I've fully equipped the maid cafe to function as a base.
Resting up is a given.
But you can also maintain and strengthen your weaponry here, too.
Maintain and strengthen your equipment?
Strengthening my weapons?
The weapon I gave you was designed to be used against regular humans.
I've given you enough power as it is, but you'll need to strengthen it to effectively destroy the zombies.
Oh, god, the zombies are gonna keep evolving, too.
Well, it's pretty powerful as it- as is.
We'll need to keep upgrading it to defeat the zombies.
I hope- my hope for this game is that there's like an endless mode or something, you know?
Of the gameplay.
You know what, maybe I should just play Vampire Survivor.
Even though I've never played it before.
There is?
Let's go.
Hey, Kanon-chan.
The zombies used to be normal people, right?
Uh-oh, uh-oh, Nagisa's thinking too hard.
These zombies used to be normal people, right?
Uh-oh, don't think about it!
Nagisa, don't think about it!
Uh...
Well, yes.
Turn off the burn!
It just makes me a bit uneasy to think about killing someone like that.
Holocure!
I've never played Holocure, either.
But I've seen some funny people, like, really enjoying it.
So maybe I'll play that, too.
Actually, that's a lie.
I have played it, like, once, I think.
It's a lie.
Play as Takanashi Kiara.
Kay is goaded.
That guy.
He's crazy.
Happy I could catch a livestream.
Thank you!
Hmm...
I mean, they could be my friends or former co-workers, you know?
Uh-oh.
A weak mindset like that is going to get you killed.
Hanya was your oshi?
Hanya's my oshi, too.
You can have more than one oshi.
Hanya's my kami oshi.
It's different.
.
She has rookie eyes...
Yeah.
.
Their brains have been invaded and destroyed.
The only thing remaining is their will to attack humans.
Yeah, I'm fine if I become infected?
It doesn't mean that it won't happen forever.
I've been bitten many times.
Maybe one day...
Also,
she is really brave.
Just standing in the street.
I was gifted a sub?
Welcome!
Besides, I doubt you want to try this.
You want to try getting minced by zombie teeth to test out that theory, correct?
Yeah, I think I'll pass.
Minto my kamiyoshi!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
For real?
Really?
You mean that?
Miss Nagisa, may I remind you...
You can't completely save a zombie.
Even if the vaccine is completed, it's impossible.
Those that have fully transformed won't be able to be saved.
It's impossible, no matter how good the vaccine may end up being.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna have to cut off Rinka's arm.
I am a human-shaped something.
Don't hesitate to shoot for Nagisa-san's sake.
They're just human-shaped, that's all.
Please don't hold back on shooting them.
For your sake as well.
Even if that means you're an important person.
If we were bitten by mint, what would we become?
I don't think you'd become a ghost.
I can scratch you guys!
I could scratch your backs.
Sometimes people don't like that though.
They're just like, I was scratched by a ghost!
And it left a mark on my back.
Happens all the time in those ghost shows.
All I'm trying to do is...
You scratch my back, I scratch yours!
No matter who you may end up facing.
I got it.
You can now purchase...
...METAL!
Oh my gosh, this is so cute!
This base is a safe zone.
You can prepare for battle here.
You can set your deployment units along with location.
You can purchase items...
Oh my gosh, there's so much going on.
Mint bite equals brain freeze.
Purchase items and power them up here.
Treatment...
You can treat any zombified maids.
You want your scratches to turn people into maids?
Do you want to become a maid?
Maid world takeover.
You can treat any zombified maids.
Select the maid that you want to treat after choosing this option.
Sub-stories...
Unlocked when certain conditions are met.
Save load...
Auto-saving the gate auto-saves after battle or any events.
These saves cannot be overwritten, but you may load from previous saves.
By pressing Y, we'll make a cursor appear which we can use to...
T-t-t-t-touch the maid!
Wait...
It's...
It's not Y on the keyboard.
What is it?
Oh, uh...
Touch Q.
Show
me what is it.
Show me what is it.
Maid old chae is so cute.
Nade nade.
So cute!
You do it.
Somebody just do something.
Watchingaxascalhooo......
See what we get.
That's for the treasure!
How did you know that's error?
But I didn't do the magic.
That's the end of the qual lightning that we didn't come here for to treat Qu affiliates.
It's me.
And there all of my P.A's...
To save your poison like WB k .
Let's save our poison.
For this
There's nothing to kill.
You're jadi, right?
See now.
Oh my gosh.
Some materials are able to be purchased, others can only be obtained through combat.
Holy cow!
Head pat the bottom right man.
No!
An opai lap pat?
Selection of items will be limited early on, but will increase based on number of areas cleared.
Additionally, some items will only appear when certain maids are deployed.
Oh...
Ninka!
This is spoilers!
Is it not?
Disposables can be selected to take into battle.
Disposable?
She's not disposable?
Ninka!
The effects of an item will last throughout the battle, but will disappear when returning to base.
Only bring one disposable.
Accessories are compatible with any maid of your choice.
Consider which accessories should be equipped with which maid depending on the situation.
Gosh, there is so much to this game!
We can get metal!
Let's buy one metal.
I don't know what it'll do.
The apocalypse doesn't look bad at all!
Powering up equipment will strengthen each maid.
Accessories, maid clothes, close range weapons, and shooting weapons need the right materials to power up.
Is she also in the title screen?
Oh yeah, how did I... Oh, it was right button for close combat stuff.
CQC.
Shooting weapons grant different bonuses based on the equipped maid.
Select a maid and choose a stat you want to increase.
By doing this, you can check what statuses can be increased.
Holy cow, this is so...
The results will be displayed during confirmation.
Whilst you need all required materials to power up items, if those missing materials are purchasable, the purchase can be made on the spot to provide...
Oh, proceed with powering up.
Each maid brings a unique sniper rifle.
Strength to the team.
Make sure to not only...
To not focus solely on increasing the strength of one, but to train a handful equally to counter any situation.
Accessories are the one selection that can be changed during deployment by choosing change accessory.
Choose the accessory you want to switch to from the accessory list.
Accessories cannot be powered up unless equipped.
Power up results and also enhance skills used in battle.
So what else can we get?
Combat knife?
Oh, one metal!
Wait, what about our rifle though?
Oh, let's do the metal... er, the rifle.
What's our accessory?
Sometimes I wonder if Mint is actually the ghost of an old man.
What?
No...
What's my inventory?
Bullets and metal.
Wait, a special bullet that can be used to befriend zombies?
Only works on maid-like zombies.
How convenient.
Wait, hold on.
Can I upgrade my weapon again?
Oh, I don't have enough money.
Okay.
Oh, my bad.
Let's go strike!
Strike!
Strike at the right time!
Yeah!
Hit him!
Knock him down now!
prisons are answered!
You can select your deployed units along with the location.
When selecting a location, you must select an area first, then choose a stage.
The condition needed to clear the stage will be displayed.
Take note that each stage has different conditions.
Playable characters are limited to maids that can be deployed.
You cannot deploy any zombified maids.
Each maid has different weapons that they are able to equip.
Additionally, they all have distinct skills and special skills.
You may bring one disposable stage.
What is the disposable?
Okay.
Red breath.
What does that mean?
Let's go.
Assist bullets.
You can fire bullets by holding down RT.
You can recruit any maids zombies from across enemy lines by shooting...
Oh my gosh!
Wait, any?
Wait, RT.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Maybe I should be playing this with a controller.
Wait, now I'm not sure at all.
These tutorials are super long-winded.
But what do I hold down?
Now I'm using my controller.
Wait, now I don't know how to do anything.
Wait.
I think...
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Check the control map?
Yeah.
So B or RT.
These will not work on giant zombies.
Assist bullets pierce through the enemy other than maids zombies and will hit any enemy within range.
Amount of bullets that can be brought into battle are limited.
Purchasing new bullets will replenish any used prior.
Okay.
Oh, and then they come and join.
If they take too much damage, they will retreat.
Oh, that's so cute!
You can have multiple allied mazes.
9 maximum.
Recruiting more mazes will result in more potential strategies in battle and strengthen your army.
Wait, I'm actually making a maid army?
MSF.
Maid sounds frontiers.
Hope you're having a fun stream!
It was my birthday yesterday, so can I...
Now justify my hip hurting sometimes.
I'm getting dizzy when I get up too fast.
It's normal for 20- Oh my god, baby.
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 22.
But yeah, as...
Oh, someone else said you should probably go see a doctor.
Happy birthday!
Okay, why is the unique skill...
Special skill gauge...
Okay, I see it.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
Oh wait, I kinda... Oh gosh, I kinda hate...
Oh god, the aiming on the controller is awful!
Oh god!
Oh god, okay, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna use...
Oh no, I can't do both.
I can't... Oh god, oh god.
It's so bad.
Okay, you know what?
Back to...
I'm gonna have to check the... What's it called?
Magnetic field?
Oh wait.
Nice!
Lightning drone!
Trying to collect more hearts.
Combat drone... Oh no, the speed!
Okay, next time we'll... Next time we get speed, you guys.
We're gonna get more speed.
Where's some...
Some little maids?
Okay, hold on.
Let's do options.
And...
Well...
I guess we'll just figure it out.
Interface spoilers.
Nah, I'm not... I wasn't even looking.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, there's so many here.
More drones!
Oh.
Optimize is pretty good too, though.
Probably should grab that.
I don't know how many...
Actually, how many skills I can get, you know?
Oh, there's so much over here.
Come on, guys.
Let's blow them up.
There's so much hearts here!
Maid?
Oh!
Wait!
You guys, I learned what my...
How to do my special attack.
I learned how to do my special attack.
We got another drone!
Oh, man.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
I'm so... Okay.
But then what could...
Oh!
Sensor?
Let's try it.
Is this like it pulls items closer to me?
Or like I can collect items more easily, you know?
What could it be?
Okay, so...
Maybe like Z or X will be it.
I'll try...
I'll try Z or X next time we see a maid.
Maid!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
More drone.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
No, don't shoot her!
Don't shoot!
My drones!
Drones!
What are you doing?
No!
Okay, here.
She's mine!
Z...
Oh!
She's dead.
Wait.
Z or X does not work.
No!
Stop killing her!
I need to practice on her!
Um...
E or R?
E!
Oh!
I didn't get to...
I didn't get to press it.
Hello!
Try right click?
That's what did my special attack.
It was Z or X for me.
But you have to hold...
Oh!
Hold it down for several seconds.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I see her!
I see her!
Z!
X!
There it is!
Oh!
Uh...
Oh...
It
went just straight past her.
Was that a big maid?
That counted as a big maid?
Oh.
Let's just keep increasing their strength.
Wait.
They're gonna kill all the maids.
She was big.
Oh!
I'll take whatever that is.
Let's see.
More drone!
Oh!
My drones are everywhere.
They're circling me everywhere.
It's a lot of drones.
Yeah, you know.
We just got to survive, right?
For five minutes?
We're so slow.
Please give us speed.
Please give us a speed power-up.
I need a maid.
Okay, so I think it was X actually that it worked on.
So, as soon as I get to her, I can stays in here.
I see a girlie.
Look at all these convenience workers.
It's so sad.
Speed?
Magnetic field.
That sounds fun.
More toilet paper.
You're going to need toilet paper if you want to survive the apocalypse, you know?
I know my special bullets limited.
And I wasted it.
I didn't realize she was a big maid.
I want to just be faster.
I know we're in like the early stages and everything.
S rank.
Anton!
Hi dog.
I can now purchase Titan silver.
And fi... fiber!
Fiber wiper!
Got a final tomorrow.
Can't stay.
Sorry.
No worries.
Good luck!
What's the clear conditions on this one?
Defeat all enemies.
We can do that.
Easy peasy.
Strike.
Let's just go.
We can do that easy.
Pause.
Yeah.
During a pause menu, you can switch between two screens.
Status.
Radar for in-range weapons.
Oh, look at that!
It tells you everything.
You can watch the events after a battle.
We need to level up.
We need to power up.
Power up.
Temporary invisibility.
Vaccine materials for bullets!
Oh!
Distribute points after battle.
Flamethrower!
Change the... yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gotta defeat all the enemies.
Oh, look at these guys.
Nice.
Let's do... let's do the magnetic field again.
Hey, give me more hearts.
Give me more hearts.
Maid!
We can actually get her on our side, maybe.
Speed!
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, I'm in trouble.
Ah, let's see.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I took some damage, but that's okay.
She's on our side!
Yippee!
We have a maid now.
How many enemies are there?
Oh, she's attacking?
She's...
Oh, god.
Uh...
Ah!
I wish I had a drone.
Oh, perfect timing.
Welcome to the army.
Welcome to the maid army.
Nice.
More drone!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I don't know what's going on.
More drone!
Increase the strength on my thing.
Oh, okay, okay.
Ah!
Oh, well.
Well, uh...
Oh my gosh, maid girls!
Be careful!
I'm clearing a path!
They follow, which is pretty cute.
Oh, is my stream buffering?
Ah, no!
I wasted my follow!
Is my stream buffering?
Oh, all good?
Okay.
Sorry if there's some weird...
It's fine.
Sorry if there's some weird YouTube stuff going on.
I don't know.
Auto heals.
Sounds kinda nice.
I wonder how it auto heals.
Let's try it.
We should probably start experimenting with more things, you know?
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
There you go, everybody.
Oh, vaccine!
Vaccine!
This one.
Nice.
Nice!
I still don't know how to slash.
I still don't know how to do the close range combat.
I can get all up in the zombies' faces and deal damage to them, so don't worry about distance.
Yeah, I know.
I know that's what it does.
What does it mean?
Mod?
What the hell?
Middle click?
Oh, let me try middle click.
Let's see.
Magnetic field 4?
Oh, it increases the range.
Or one word, road.
Let's increase the range.
No, middle click isn't doing anything.
Oh, that's a big girl.
That's a big girl.
Oh!
How could Mint forget the basics of CQC?
I'm honestly...
How am I supposed to defeat all of these?
Yes!
More drones.
I wish I could get more mates as well.
We're close to being...
We're close to being able to use our attack, our special.
Just use our special.
There it is.
Hold on!
There's more falling from the sky.
Somebody dropped their toilet paper.
More drones.
More movement.
Oh my god.
Speed.
Thank god.
Forty percent?
Hell yeah.
Okay.
All right.
They're starting to dwindle a little bit.
We're doing well.
Max.
Let's just max this guy out, you know.
Oh, the otaku!
Oh!
You were like a death ball.
I know.
It's awesome, right?
How many more guys are there?
I say...
More drones!
Ah!
Yeah!
Hello, drones.
More mates!
I haven't seen any other girl...
Any other mate girls.
Oh!
I haven't seen any.
We haven't tried the grenades.
Let's try stuff like this, you know.
We haven't tried anything like this.
Do I just throw them out?
Oh, I throw them out.
Okay.
Perfect.
I don't have to, like, select it or anything.
Cool.
Oh!
Watch out for the fire.
Oh my god.
I am so powerful.
Look at this.
Increases drones.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
I'm a little ball of death, right?
They ambushed me like that.
Oh, my health did heal.
That's so awesome.
Your own fire is probably safe.
I guess we'll see.
Land mine.
Plant a bomb on...
You know what?
Let's try it.
We have still quite a few amount of skill points.
Let's go test my fire.
Oh!
Okay.
It's gone.
Really?
Oh!
Oh, this is the bomb.
I'm planting bombs.
Get her.
No damage.
Yeah.
Nice.
Drone maids.
Yes.
Yippee!
More speed.
Okay.
How are you doing, my little maids?
Oh, my god.
Oooooooh!
Don't get hurt.
Ahh!
Oh, my god.
Oh, I don't have my skill.
My skill is not...
Let's see.
Uhm...
More drone strength.
Luckily, the land mines like kind of...
Oh, my god.
The maids like kind of get in my way.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
They make it... they like push me.
I have to like push through them, you know?
Don't let the maids die.
Oh, more drones!
Perfect.
Perfection.
I know what can solve any horrible situation.
Oh my god, stop landing on me!
I don't know what my HP is at.
But it does heal by itself.
Oh my gosh, little maids.
I need you to move.
Maids.
Maids, please.
I want the toilet paper.
Oh no!
Oh no, we lost one.
We lost a maid.
Your maid army is to die for.
We lost a maid, you guys.
Probably should do my...
Holy cow!
Holy cow.
Yippee!
She went out as a human.
So true.
It's not that they run away.
I think she's alright.
You can't convert the big maids?
No, you can't.
Only the small maids.
That one was fine.
Let's see what we can upgrade now.
Or rather, can we buy anything?
What can we buy?
Why?
Bullet.
Oh yeah, this is the special.
Oh, we only have one left, so...
Oh, they're cheap.
They're really cheap.
Oh, I can only buy two.
Okay.
I need...
vaccines to make the bullets.
Okay, understandable, understandable.
Okay.
I have four of those.
No.
Five, six...
Okay.
Let's upgrade some stuff.
Let's upgrade our rifle.
Yes.
Nice.
What about my maid outfit?
Oh, fiber.
Upgrade.
How much money do I have?
Where is my money?
Anyway, let's just spend it all.
I don't know where my money is.
Fiber wiper.
My speed went up?
No way.
Oh, it does.
It increases your defense speed and HP.
Let's do it again, then.
Where's my money?
How much money do I have?
Six thousand...
Wait, how do you guys see it?
Oh, I see.
MP is possession.
I see.
We are gonna be so strong.
I would upgrade my combat knife more, but like, I don't know how to use it, so...
Producer's sign?
Pretty much.
Okay, that should be good.
I think for now.
What's the clear conditions?
Defeat the boss!
Don't forget to save.
Oh, it auto-saves, though, right?
If you don't look at your money, it's like you're not spending it.
Oh, I see.
I do that all the time.
All right, let's go try.
Striker!
Yeah, it auto-saves.
Oh!
Have you found any signs of Ms. Rinka's whereabouts?
No.
I still haven't found anything.
To be honest, I haven't found anything.
What are we gonna do, then?
No, not yet.
I don't even know where I should be looking.
Yeah.
I thought so.
Akihabara isn't really that big, but searching while having to fight off zombies is no easy task.
I mean, I've been like in the same street.
An impostor of the boss.
No matter where I find her, I've made up my mind that I'll be the one to save her.
Her radar is going off.
I can't help but find it a bit strange.
Why are you so dead set on finding Miss Rinka?
You think it's weird?
Isn't it normal to want to save a friend?
Oh, sorry!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where's the log?
It'll mean risking your own life, though.
I don't understand the logic of wanting to do that when she isn't even a family member.
Are you saying you have to have some kind of reason before you can save her?
That's not it.
I'm asking you if this reason of yours is worth putting your life on the line for.
A reason to risk my life...
A reason...
I didn't really think about it, but maybe it's because we're friends.
The reason I put myself in danger, huh?
I mean, I didn't really think too much of it.
Wait, think of it too much.
But it's because she's my friend.
That's not the answer.
You didn't answer my question.
But it's the truth!
Friend...
I'm not lying, though!
Rinka-chan is the same age as me, though.
At the maid cafe after work, she was a bit older than me.
Rinka is the same age as me, but she started working at the maid cafe before I did.
This is the place she used to work at.
Ah, that must be the cafe that we're using as a base right now.
She's got them crazy eyes again.
And on my first shift, she ended up being the one to teach me the ropes.
I thought she was reserved and a little scary in the beginning.
But she'd always come to my rescue when I missed her.
We went to different universities, but we'd always hang out when we could.
And before I realized it, we were always together.
So you're her best friend?
A best friend of sorts.
Is that it?
Yeah, something like that.
You could say that.
Besides, Rinka saved me when the pandemic broke out.
Rinka even saved me just as the pandemic was beginning.
When we were setting up the maid cafe, the zombies suddenly started attacking us.
When we were handing out flyers, some people that had turned into zombies started attacking us.
I didn't know what was going on, so I couldn't move.
John did a plot twist.
Rinka changed me from a zombie.
I was frozen in place.
I was frozen in place with everything that was going on.
But Rinka saved me from the zombies.
I like the music in this game a lot.
Hold on, I'm going to get a cough drop real quick.
I have one.
I got one.
Give me one second to put it in.
Thinking back, that must have been the moment that she was bitten and got infected by the virus.
Please.
Very like-minded.
What did you say?
Did you say something?
No.
More importantly, it's about Rinka-san's creation.
It seems that the inside of that building is full of zombies.
If we were in the UDX area, it's more like this direction.
Behind you guys.
Behind chat.
It's nothing.
Anyway.
In regards to searching for Ms. Rinka.
The building over there seems to be a gathering spot for the zombies.
Nagisa-san isn't that far away from the place where she broke up with Ms. Rinka.
There's a possibility that she might have been drawn to it.
Yeah, it's really nice.
And then also, just like, all the soundtrack for this is really good.
Like the rock parts too.
They haven't left the area where you and Ms. Rinka split.
Which means there might be some sort of clue around them.
Really?
Then I'll go take care of it right away!
And I need to get a move on!
Oh, indoor zombie.
Please do your best to be careful.
Battling zombies indoors is going to be much more of a challenge than usual.
If you fight while being careful, you'll be fine.
And when the time comes, Kanon-chan will help you, right?
Well, make sure to be extra careful then.
Don't worry about it.
Plus, you'll save me if I need it, right?
If I'm not in the area, I'll be in trouble if someone asks me for help.
Seeing as I won't be there for you, you might have a hard time calling me for help.
Sorry, sorry!
Silly me!
Well then, how about we reunite the zombies?
In order to save Rinka-chan!
Yeah, I'm gonna beat those zombies for Rinka's sake!
Oh my god, she zoomed off!
Kanon, you okay?
For the sake of my friends.
I don't think Kanon has any friends.
For your friend.
Miracle.
I hope she wakes up.
We're gonna need a miracle.
Pizza?
Oh my god!
Give me hearts!
Drown!
Give me more hearts!
Give me hearts!
You guys want brains, I want hearts!
Oh, nice!
Yoshi!
I don't know what that just implied but...
Oh, gosh.
There's even this wall here.
Yoshi!
Let's also do the grenade.
I think this can be a pretty good passive.
Oh my gosh, wait.
You guys, we're about to get... oh gosh.
I think that was my skill that I heard.
I thought we were about to get... what's the word?
Trapped?
More drone!
Let's do more drone.
A dog!
Oh my god, you guys.
I'm a terrible... no.
It's just dog-shaped.
It's not a dog.
It's just dog-shaped, you guys.
It's dog-shaped.
It's not real.
Okay, can you stop throwing the grenades like in useless places?
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Just ignore him.
Just ignore that.
Oh my god, the drones take care of him for me.
I have no guilt.
Magnetic field!
He's just a boy!
He looks kind of aggressive, though.
Let's do the auto-heal as well.
It's pretty good to have.
Nice.
Oh!
Nice!
Okay.
Having at least two maids on our side is pretty good, I'd say.
Alright, girls.
Let's fight.
Heaven or hell.
You're going somewhere tonight.
Hello, I'm so late.
Hello!
All you missed was there's a zombie apocalypse and we fight in Akihabara as a maid.
Nice.
Nice!
I love drones.
Does it feel like... It doesn't really feel like we're that much faster, I'll be honest.
Let's see.
Oh, the optimized... Oh, shoot.
I should have grabbed that.
I'll get it when it comes back around.
Where's the boss?
Where's the boss, after all?
Drones are the future.
The
song's on rotation.
Let's see.
Oh, this is the max.
We'll do the max.
Oh, what's that?
Ooh.
Oh, I think that's the thing that helps us get more...
Uh, stuff for...
Leveling up.
For skills.
Oh, I just realized the normal grenade.
We've been using the fire grenade.
I like the fire grenade, though.
Guys, we're at max dronage.
We're at max dronage, I believe.
Um...
Oh, never mind.
We can always have more drones.
Oh, gosh!
I just noticed their shadows as they came down on me.
No!
Die, zombie!
Everybody must die!
Oh, my god!
Holy moly.
Uh...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, god.
Girlies.
Girlies, move out.
Move out, girlies.
Move out, move out.
I gotta be more...
The shadows show up and, like, the...
They drop down so quickly.
See?
Oh, there it is.
Watch out, watch out, watch out!
I got you, I got you!
Oh, more, more, more!
I got you, I got you.
Hmm...
We can do more power.
Holy cow.
Watch out!
Oh, oh, lolololo.
Strength.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, my god.
Watch out, girls.
Watch out!
We gotta get out of this corner.
Come on!
Keep walking!
Yeah!
They're all getting taken out.
Let's do a tackle.
There we go.
The faster we can attack, the better.
And my health is healing.
It's auto-heal, so it's not bad at all.
These guys are all...
Holy cow!
There's so many of them!
Just drop the...
Ow!
Uh-oh.
What's going on?
I hear footsteps.
Oh, my god.
There's blood everywhere.
I missed the giant...
I missed the treasure.
Oh, well.
I didn't realize how dark it'd be in here without the lights on.
If I don't pay close attention, I might trip and fall over something.
Oh, what was that?
Oh.
Oh, no!
I'm a zombie.
Miss Nagisa, on your right is some shattered glass.
You'll be fine with those shoes, but please be wary.
Ah?
Why is there a piece of glass there?
Did you know that?
You know I can't see the situation, do you?
How do you know about the glass, Ganon?
You can't see what's going on, can you?
I have a small camera on my phone.
Oh?
Oh!
The codec.
There's a miniature camera in the communication device.
I can switch it to night vision mode.
So everything is crystal clear to me.
I love her outfit, oh my gosh.
Combat made, so awesome.
Wait!
Her uniform is kind of similar to mine, isn't it?
With like the...
With her collar, and then my collar, and then...
Oh, mine... the only difference is mine is off the shoulder sleeves.
Huh!
How funny.
Technology sure is impressive these days.
However,
using the camera will run down the battery, so I won't be using it for long.
All you need is an assault rifle.
So true.
Mint, fit it better?
No.
Stab.
It's pretty small, so the battery isn't anything special.
Sending video through constantly will drain it quickly.
Yeah, it's like I'm a maid or something.
Crazy.
I guess even this has a weakness.
I can't tell if it's useful or not when you say it like that.
It's just a machine.
In situations like these, I don't really rely on it that much.
It's just a machine at the end of the day, so relying on it too much wouldn't be wise.
After the pandemic, the power supply has stopped, and the power is out of charge.
Because of the pandemic, a lot of places are out of power.
Charging it could be troublesome.
To tell you the truth, the reason for releasing the zone controlled by zombies was to set up power facilities and to restore power.
Oh...
Oh, to be frank, we're trying to take back this area from the zombies in order to gain access to a power generator.
Who is we?
You, Kanon?
I'm trying to find my friend.
You really are thinking this through, aren't you, Kanon?
We is you.
Me and you?
I didn't agree to this.
More battle made mint art ideas.
For vaccine... Sorry if you can hear my chair popping.
Oh my goodness.
From vaccine making to researching the virus, electricity is going to be a major factor we'll have to consider.
Oh my god.
Am I going to become an electrician too?
Though it's been a while.
Before the pandemic, I used to have lunch around here often.
Chair upgrade when?
When this chair...
I truly can't sit my butt anymore.
You too, Kanon?
We used to come here before, actually.
Does that mean you used to work in Akihabara too?
I think Kanon is the cause of the virus.
You there?
What was it?
Seems like it.
But for one to have that sort of agility...
You must be serious, Kanon.
I didn't know that this cafe made you have a color-coded, you know, panties too.
Zombie.
Oh my gosh, look at her.
Wow, oh my gosh.
Wait.
Twins?
Do they have the same garter belt even?
You guys have the same garter belt even.
Twins?
Oh my god, Rinka is the boss.
Same underwear too.
I'm not showing you that.
That's her?
We?
Who is we?
There is no we in this fandom.
Rinka-chan!
Nagisa!
It's me, Nagisa!
It's dangerous, Nagisa-san.
Rinka-san is already at the edge.
Oh, Rinka is already starting to transform.
I think she... I mean...
Yeah?
We painted some of this screenshot green.
Ay ay ay ay ay.
But... but...
She isn't attacking.
If she's a zombie, she'll attack you with her impulsive attacks.
Oh my god, speak up, Kannon.
I can't hear you over this sick rift.
What?
Zombies should automatically start attacking any human they can see.
Could she have heard Ms. Nagisa's voice and stopped attacking?
No, a virus at this level would block out anything like that.
Kannon-chan!
What should I do?
Oh, sorry, rift.
What should I do to save Rinka-chan?
This rift in my heart.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no, no.
This too is Yuri.
Nice rift.
Oh my god.
What should I do?
How do I save her?
If Ms. Rinka is still aware, then her brain must not have been fully infected yet.
Oh my god.
Kiss her.
She's only a partial zombie.
In other words, she's only a partial zombie.
Maybe she's resisting.
Her body must be fighting the virus as we speak.
That means if we just give her the vaccine, she'll get better, right?
That means if we jab her with the vaccine, she'll go back to normal, right?
That's possible.
But it's not a start.
She's probably losing her mind.
Oh, oh, oh.
There's a chance, but her condition is getting worse and she's losing awareness by the minute.
Okay, but quit your yapping then.
Holding her down and bringing her back to base like that is going to be risky.
If there's even a sliver of a chance, I want to take it.
Understood.
Hold her down!
I'll be preparing the vaccine as planned.
Dang, Kanon is so fast.
The zombie apocalypse just happened like today and she's already got a vaccine.
Wow.
Should've put her in charge of the 2020 pandemic.
Also, if we can get samples from someone else who didn't immediately transform, that'd also help my research.
Thank you, Kanon-chan!
But the only person who can stop Rinka-san from moving and bring her back is Nagisa-san.
But understand that you're the only one who can stop Miss Rinka and bring her back here.
Yup!
I understand!
Let's shoot her!
...It's gonna be alright, Rinka-chan.
We'll definitely save you no matter what!
We'll save you no matter what.
She's like...
Oh my god, oh my god !!
Rika-chan...
...it is you Chief...
I mean, back mid-battle.
Watch out, girls!
Don't take any more damage like that.
You're scaring me.
More vaccine stuff.
How are my maids doing?
Where are my maids?
Oh, there's one left!
Gosh, I'm gonna get cornered here.
I'm gonna get cornered here.
Oh no!
Oh, I think we got...
I can't see myself, I have so many drones.
I had too many drones, you couldn't even see my little sprite.
Yay!
Super bar is full, but you don't even need it.
Yeah, we're all good.
I'm going back to base.
After the battle with Rinka ended, I carried her back to base because she was too exhausted to move.
As Kanon-chan said, as expected, I'm not a complete zombie yet.
I think...
I think it's supposed to say, it was just as Kanon had said.
Rinka's body was in the process of transforming.
If the treatment goes well, Rinka-chan will be healed.
But, if it doesn't...
If everything goes well, then she'll return to normal.
But if she doesn't, I don't know what I'll do.
Fire the cannon, Kanon.
Wait, why is there...
Why does this exist in the maid cafe?
Miss Nagisa, everything is ready.
Oh yeah, sometimes they put two ends for Kanon, and sometimes just one.
It's... it's okay, we're not here so much for this.
Translation, right?
If it goes well, then we'll be able to fix Miss Rinka just as planned.
This one.
What if the vaccine doesn't work as intended?
Yeah.
I know.
So please.
Just please go through with it.
I didn't have to say anything.
Well then, let's start the treatment.
Role play room?
Probably.
This is probably the maid cafe next door.
It's hospital themed.
And you sit... you have to lay in your bed and eat your food that way.
I guess I don't need to say anymore.
Well then, let us begin the procedure.
Saving.
I don't think we need to save her at all.
I don't think... this is... this is...
We don't need to save her at all.
What are you talking about?
Let her... let her stay, please!
Oh my god, no.
No, please.
Don't make me do this.
She's perfect.
She's perfect the way she is.
Oh my god.
The teeth.
The eyes.
The skin.
Aaaaaah!
You can fix her.
She's our...
She's... this is an improvement.
She's already fixed.
Why is the music so loud?
You can treat any zombified maids.
Maids will become zombified if you defeat them as enemies and take them back to base.
Or if they are defeated in battle after deployment.
Oh my god.
She's so cute.
Zombified maids cannot be deployed.
Make sure to treat them immediately.
Furthermore...
If all of your maids have been zombified, it will result in a game over.
Game, please!
Game!
To heal, you need a vaccine.
If you run out, you can purchase them in the item shop.
By shaking vaccine bottles, you can max out their shake gauge.
Once full, treatment will be applied to the target.
I don't think that's...
What kind of vaccine is this?
Hey, no spoilers!
By spreading the vaccine, the patient will slowly heal.
Make sure to spread it around enough until they are fully recovered.
Why is it a topical vaccine?
I could fix her.
I just don't want to.
Maids that have already completed their treatment can skip this option during the base treatment selection.
I'm shaking it.
I'm sorry that I must cure you.
I'm sorry.
This is... I'm... I'm... I'm sorry.
You were perfect the way you were, Dinka.
I could... I would... I would take you as you were.
Okay, using medicine, go!
The color is returning to her eyes!
Shiko, shiko, shiko.
Shiko, shiko.
I love live 2D.
Shiko, shiko, shiko.
Shiko, shiko.
You guys, it's medicine!
This is... This is for... medicinal purposes.
I walked all the way... away for 30 minutes?
Yeah.
She looks concerned?
I mean, she was a zombie.
Don't worry about it.
I'm just... I'm just jorking it in the hospital real quick.
And by it, I mean my medicine.
Again?
More?
I think she's okay.
Oh, nope.
Let's keep going.
Oh, never mind.
Success!
Stop it, Shinji!
That's what... yeah, Shinji was doing, maybe.
Oh, you're still here?
Yeah.
I wanted to be by Rinka-chan's side.
See, you don't know when you'll wake up, right?
I think we all should have assumed that it would be a topical medicine.
I'm jorking my medicine right now, too.
I don't wanna know... I don't know what... You know what?
You're being healthy.
Everybody, jork your medicine.
Take your vitamins, okay?
I wanted to be with Rinka.
We don't know when she'll wake up, you know?
I understand how you feel, but Nagisa-san is also tired.
I'm so messed up.
She fought so many zombies.
She needs to rest a little.
I understand how you feel, but you must be exhausted as well.
Don't forget that you need to rest, too.
I can't afford to rest.
Take your meds.
If Rinka-chan doesn't get better soon, we might have to fight again.
I can't afford to rest now.
If Rinka wakes up and she's not healed, I'll have to fight again.
If that happens, it'll be dangerous for Kano-chan alone.
If I close my eyes, I'll be reminded of all the bad things I've done.
I'll be reminded of all the bad things I've done.
And you made fun of me for making a joke in a joke a while ago.
Oh my gosh.
Angel, I'm so sorry I missed your very spooky dono earlier.
Finally back from the US and can enjoy my Kamiyoshi live again without having grass to touch or some such.
Just so you know, this trip never would have happened if it wasn't for you, so thank you.
What?
I did nothing.
Thank you!
If it comes to that, then you'll be in danger too.
Besides, every time I close my eyes, all I see is unpleasant memories of the medicine.
Every time I close my eyes, I imagine the medicines.
But if Miss Rinka doesn't revert back, I'm pretty sure it worked.
I'm just saying.
Boys, we know how to stop the apocalypse.
Do you have the antibodies?
To stop the apocalypse?
I know it needs to be done.
But I believe that it won't come to that.
Rinka is strong.
She'll definitely recover.
Only one way to find out.
You could be one in a million.
I'll be continuing my efforts in refining the vaccine.
I think it works perfectly fine.
So please keep an eye on Miss Rinka.
Just like my Japanese anime.
She's awake.
She needs a shower, probably.
Never mind.
It all absorbed into her skin.
Wow.
Where am I?
Rinka-chan!
Wake up!
Why are you...
I don't remember.
I'm sure...
Yeah, the underwear is color-coded.
It is, it is.
And then...
Nakisa, why are you...
I remember getting bit by a zombie and...
You don't remember?
You forgot what happened?
I don't know.
I can't wait until we get our next girl.
What happened after you broke up with Nakisa?
I don't know.
I remember we split up, but...
Everything after that...
Is hazy.
Just a reminder.
Kanon made the vaccine and decided it should be a topical.
Yeah, I think we should infect Rinka again.
I'm just saying.
Seems like your memories from after you were bitten have been affected.
Do you feel sick?
Or dizzy, perhaps?
I mean, look at this CG.
It's so cute.
Look at them.
So cute.
And now this one...
Who are you?
Self introduction and explanation later.
First, you are to check how well Rinka is.
Hmm.
Let's say the formalities for later.
Our first priority is to check you over and see how you're doing.
You may have had a variant of the virus yet...
Oh no, I've been bit.
...
extra experiences.
I have the vaccine.
Shuko.
You still may have some lingering effects from the virus.
So it's important to do a thorough check.
Virus...
The virus, huh?
Why aren't her clothes destroyed here?
Cowards.
I see.
You were the one that made the vaccine.
Thank you so much.
I wouldn't be here without you.
All I did was make it.
The one that saved you was Miss Nagisa.
Vaccine fixed the clothes too?
Not in the CG!
Even after being attacked by zombies, she never gave up.
She was determined to save you.
Nagisa, you risked your life for me?
Are you mad, Rinka?
Why would she be mad?
A little.
A little?
I'm grateful for your help.
But...
I can't believe I'm doing something so dangerous.
Of course I'm...
Oh, a little.
Of course I'm grateful that you saved me.
But you put yourself in so much danger.
Rinka, you're too cool.
Oh.
Says the person who's always trying to play it cool and save others.
What?
Rinka, you sacrificed yourself to save me.
You sacrificed your own safety for my sake too.
I want to save Rinka too.
I wanted to save her.
Oh my god, her...
I wanted to save you.
That's what I did.
Now we're even, okay?
Rinka's face.
Rinka's so cute.
All of them are very cute.
Kyurei is always really good at making very cute girls.
Fine.
Let's just leave it at that.
If I were Nagisa, I would have done the same thing.
I would have done the same thing if I were you.
Now that you have two mates, you'll be able to apply twice as much vaccine to the next girl.
You're better than me, Rinka.
I can hear you, you know.
Nagisa-san, let's stop talking.
Rinka has just woken up.
She needs to rest.
Okay.
You too.
Let it be for now.
Ms. Rinka just woke up, so she'll need a bit more rest.
Did Kyurei make me in?
No.
They didn't.
Sounds like a good idea.
Thanks, Kanon.
You're the reason we could save Rinka in the end.
No.
Nagisa-san believed in Rinka-san.
To be honest, it was a miracle that Rinka-san was treated.
Made you lose your nose.
What are you talking about?
We were able to save her because you believed in her.
To be honest, this is nothing short of a miracle.
Is that so?
But there was a vaccine.
Yes.
But this wasn't thanks to the vaccine?
I mean, yes, it was.
What?
What are you talking about?
It worked!
We still don't know exactly how effective it is.
And to be honest, I don't...
I didn't think situations like Rinka's were possible.
Just so you know, I did a test.
Rinka-san had the same thing as Nagisa-san.
She had antibodies against the virus.
I'm so distracted.
When Kanon talks, there's like a little part here that like...
Like the pixels like start going a little wonky.
I wanted to make sure, so I ran a couple of tests.
And it seems Miss Rinka also carries an antibody that helped her fight the infection.
Just like you!
I wonder where she got that from.
She's the same as me.
But...
Isn't that strange?
I'm not a zombie.
Why is Rinka-chan the only one?
The same as me?
But that doesn't make sense.
I didn't transform at all.
The antibodies don't completely prevent infection and infection.
See it?
Nagisa-san, if you get bitten by a lot of zombies, you might get infected.
Antibodies don't completely block the virus.
So it's possible you might still transform if bitten enough.
Don't scare me, Kanon-chan!
What happens here too.
I see it now.
Don't scare me like that!
Kanon!
It's a fact.
Don't forget about it.
The antibodies are not all-purpose.
It was the harvest that confirmed that.
But it's the truth.
So please don't forget it.
Those antibodies aren't perfect.
Though I'm glad we figured that out from this whole ordeal.
However, even if it does happen, if you have the antibodies, you can slow down the zombie-ization.
The pixels on her glasses move.
I know!
It's kind of distracting.
Even if someone were to start having symptoms, it seems as though the antibodies slowed down the entire process.
I'm starting to think this game may not be scientifically accurate.
This information will be useful in the future.
No...
They've consulted so many doctors for this game, I think.
If we act fast during that phase, we may be able to stop the zombie-ification.
This is useful information to have.
Oh my gosh.
I want a zombified...
Oh, I can't wait to find our next zombified girl.
Give it to me.
Then, if we can make enough vaccines, everyone would have the antibodies, right?
That'd make the virus a lot easier to deal with.
Yes.
I hope we can end the pandemic.
Napmas!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Maybe the key to ending this pandemic...
What if...
Yeah, what if we zombified Nagisa?
Will it work if she gets caught?
If she, like...
The next girl is going to make me happy.
Though we still need more samples from others with the antibody to make a stronger vaccine.
Rinka and I won't be enough?
No!
She's going to drain your body of blood?
Yes.
To do that, we need to find survivors.
I hope they're maids.
It's always better to have more samples.
So we'll have to search for more survivors that are potential carriers.
Got it!
If that's the case, I'll do something!
It's the Maid of Geons!
The Maid of Geons!
We can find survivors and protect them, right?
That sounds like something I can do.
We just have to find survivors and protect them, right?
Zombie canon.
Is that okay?
I'm sure Nagisa-san has already achieved her goal.
We don't need to put her in any more danger.
You're fine with doing that?
I thought your goal had already been achieved.
I don't know why you'd want to danger your own life further.
I mean, it may... think about it.
You guys can't stay cramped in this little maid cafe.
You have to, you know?
The reason I was able to save Rinka-chan was thanks to you, Canon-chan.
Besides, once the vaccine is completed, everyone will be happy, right?
We were able to save Rinka because of your efforts.
So if we can make a stronger vaccine, more people will end up being saved, right?
Then there's no reason not to do it, right?
If it's something I can do, I'm willing to do anything.
If that's the case, then of course I have to help.
Just let me know what to do.
Sounds like Nagisa-san.
Someone needs to go get the toilet paper.
I understand.
Exactly.
I'll listen to you.
You mostly stay cramped in a maid cafe.
Shut up.
I'm haunting.
It's different.
It sounds just like you, Miss Nagisa.
In that case, I'll leave it up to you.
We should start by taking back some of the areas overrun with zombies and creating safe zones.
Yeah.
And then we'll investigate those said areas.
Got it!
Alright!
I'm motivated!
I can do this!
Yow!
I'm getting pumped!
I'll do my best!
Yeah!
Ugh.
My throat is starting to hurt.
What the...
That was so fast.
Is it true you found survivors, Kanon?
I was able to confirm that someone had shot off some fireworks.
That was the fastest.
She just like stepped out for two seconds.
Fireworks?
It could be that someone was trying to call out for help with them.
They're probably in need of food or water or something.
Okay, we gotta go get the new girl.
I can't wait to see her.
Wouldn't that be dangerous though?
I mean, don't you think the zombies would notice it?
I'm sure it was a last resort of sorts.
They must be desperate for help.
We have to save them as quick as we can.
They might be getting attacked by zombies right this second.
I think we should be the first ones to do so.
Des... Despre...
Sorry, I didn't even notice it.
Despre...
You're getting desperate, everybody.
Other survival?
The other's survival might be our biggest priority right now.
Some of them could possibly be carrying the antibody we need.
You're the only one that can do this, Miss Nagisa.
If Kanon was in charge of carrying the big sea, it would have been over in two months.
That's what I'm saying!
We all need a Kanon.
We need a Kanon in this world.
You're the only one that can do this, Miss Nagisa.
Are there any objections?
Of course!
Kanon-chan will support you with her transmitter.
Any objections?
Equips the gun, puts on her crazy face.
None at all!
I'd really appreciate it if you could provide backup on the communicator again.
Wait a minute...
Rinko-chan, are you okay?
Are you sure it's okay for you to be up and moving already?
Yes.
I think I'm fine now.
I feel like my body is lighter than before.
I feel fine.
In fact, I feel lighter than ever if I'm being honest.
Anyway, Nagisa.
You were trying to do something dangerous again, weren't you?
No...
Nagisa, were you trying to do something risky all by yourself again?
Weren't... Oh, you were trying to do... trying to do something risky all by yourself again.
Weren't you?
You heard me?
Why is the music so ominous?
I heard you.
I was trying to listen in, but your voice was just as loud as ever.
Nagisa, please don't do anything reckless by yourself.
Please don't do anything reckless by yourself?
Okay, then come with me!
But I can fight zombies!
There are people I can save!
But I'm the only one that can fight the zombies!
And there might be others out there that I can save!
I know.
That's why.
Oh, that's why?
Which is why I was thinking...
I'll go with you.
I'll go along with you.
Wait, Rinka-chan?
How did you get that gun?
It's too cool.
I know, right?
I love the katana, too.
The weaponry should have been locked.
The security seems to be weak.
If you mess with the lock a little, you'll be able to get it out.
She picked the lock?
The security isn't all that tight.
I just played around with the lock a little and voila.
If I have this, I can fight zombies.
Besides, my body that has overcome the virus...
My body is the same as Nagisa's, right?
But with this, I can fight against them, too.
And my body is like Nagisa's, right?
I was infected, too, after all.
Why was there... Where did she...
Okay, but where did Kanon get all these weapons?
And just stored them here?
You even read my science reports.
You're a lot more cunning than you look.
I'll take that as a compliment.
Wait a minute!
Rika-chan is fighting a zombie...
Are you serious?
Stop asking questions.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Are you seriously planning on fighting zombies?
That's what I'm thinking.
Maybe...
I can't rely on you?
That's the plan.
Or are you saying I'd be in the way?
That's not true!
Rather, it's very reliable.
But...
Even though it's the end of the world, I don't want you to be so reckless.
Not at all.
I'd feel better if I had you with me.
I just don't want to put you in danger.
I told you.
I'm in the same body as you.
You don't need to worry about me.
My body is the same as yours now.
There's no need to worry about me.
Besides, Nagisa is a little clumsy.
If you don't keep an eye on her, I'll be worried.
Besides, you're quite the klutz, Nagisa.
I'd feel more nervous leaving you all alone.
Thank you, Mint.
I don't think I'm that much of a klutz.
Do you remember how many plates you broke at work?
I remember you spilling ketchup on your own.
And then...
Do you remember how many plates you broke at the cafe?
You even squirted ketchup in a customer's face by accident.
Not to mention.
I know!
You don't need to say all that in front of Kanon!
Sorry, I got a little carried away.
Yeah, let's go.
I'm ready to play the game.
Let's get going.
There's people out there that need our help.
Yes!
Add her to the little menu.
You can now deploy.
Hairpin.
Sub-story, nice.
Hold on before we do this.
She gets so angry.
Sorry, sorry.
Okay.
Let's go to the workshop.
And upgrade stuff.
So how do I change...
Oh, wait.
How do I change now to...
Oh, there we go.
Perfect.
So let's upgrade...
How much money do I have?
Oh, 8,000.
Okay, perfect.
Let's upgrade her a couple times.
We need more fiber.
Sniper rifle.
Nice.
I don't remember what... Hold on.
Four, five...
How can I get...
Change accessory.
Yeah, we have none.
Let's see if we can buy anything.
We said we could buy a hairpin, right?
Whoa!
Accessory...
Special Arcana brand chip.
Increases power and point growth.
It's expensive.
20k.
Here we go.
How much money did I have?
3,000?
Okay.
That should be good for now.
Yeah, we're gonna have to save up.
We're gonna have to save up, baby.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait till our maid cafe is full.
It's gonna be so cute.
Okay.
I'm excited.
Oh gosh, I can't wait to see who the next girl is.
Idle!
Idle?
Minto.
Rinka got a PSG-1.
Hurry and save Meryl.
Confirm deployment.
Yeah!
So I think this one is just survive for five minutes?
Wait, where is...
Where is she?
Oh my god.
They got...
The zombies have knives now.
Are these cosplayers?
Oh, I forgot to swap.
I thought that they would both be able to come out at once.
Aw, man.
But it said that they were both required.
Hmm.
Space.
Oh, this looks like the end of the map.
Nice.
Missile?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
What was the miniature missile?
Look how cute the sprites are.
They're so cute.
What was that sound?
Oh, my special is ready.
Oh, this is a smaller map, actually.
We'll do the...
Oh, auto heal or magnetic field.
Let's do it.
Hmm.
Yes!
Magnetic field!
La la la.
Yeah.
I'm still slow.
I'm still so slow.
I like the incendiary garlic.
I like these ones too.
Because they blow up and also leave a lasting.
You know?
Oh!
Vacuum!
Nice.
Vacuum.
Let's do it.
Oh, that's why...
So they stay in place.
So that's why they kind of like...
don't hang around me.
And sometimes there will be places that are filmed.
With hearts.
And I'm like...
How?
Why?
I'm trying to get these hearts in here.
Optimize!
Oh!
What did I do?
How did I get this?
I want the missiles to come back.
What a waste.
Flamethrower.
So nice.
Oh!
I think I saw some otaku-chan!
Hello!
Oh!
There's a main too!
They're coming out.
Oh!
There's a big girl!
I keep getting hurt.
My bad.
I don't even know my own...
My own hitbox, I guess.
Don't get hurt!
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
And I have my special if I need to use it.
I haven't forgotten.
Oh!
What the hell?
What is my hitbox?
Grenade!
Sensor.
More drones!
I just noticed a friend.
Yeah, she's helping us out.
She's so cute.
Oh my god, there's so many otaku.
Otaku!
Oh!
Miniature missile!
Let's see how this works.
I'm so curious.
Homing bullet!
Oh!
All the designs are so cute.
I know, right?
Oh!
I was pressing...
I don't think I have any more bullets left.
For support mages.
Okay.
I'll have to make more.
I'll have to make more support mages.
I mean, more bullets for support mages.
Take a...
Yay!
Oh!
On
the way.
On the way.
I need to get more hearts.
Please.
Please move.
Left
click does the melee?
Oh!
You looked it up!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
You're right!
Oh!
Okay.
But there's a...
There's a...
There's a slowdown on it.
Okay.
So if I'm like...
Oh!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Mid!
Get him, I...
Get him...
Ah!
Get...
Oh my god.
This guy has...
Pant lights!
Oh, I think we lost our mid.
I think we lost our mid maybe.
Oh no.
Okay, now we know how to fight.
Oh my goodness.
Let's increase the strength of this.
Oh!
This is perfect.
Perfect timing.
Oh!
Perfect timing!
Oh yeah!
Perfect timing, baby!
Perfect timing!
Why are the mids so much stronger now?
There's another one right here.
Cool down.
What did I just get?
Speed.
There was some more stuff up here, but...
Um...
More...
Let's increase our drones-ness.
Oh my gosh.
Wee!
Oh, gosh.
Oh,
they're really starting to get stronger.
You guys are taking damage!
Uh-oh.
Oh, we made it.
No!
I took damage!
Oh
no!
I took too much damage.
Where were you?
Stunned the fuck out of me.
The fight is finally over.
Oh yeah, it totally looked like you knew what you were doing out there.
Her face.
I don't think it was anything special.
I was totally surprised at how calm and collected you were despite everything.
She looks so...
Did you used to be a mercenary by any chance?
Ooh,
it sounds like something out of a manga, huh?
Stories about ex-mercenaries are pretty popular now, aren't they?
Is this a gacha game?
No, it's not.
It's not a gacha game.
You know that I'm just a regular college student, Nagisa.
FPS.
Though I guess I have pretty good hand-eye coordination.
I mean, I'm pretty into shooter games.
She's a gamer!
You like video games?
Yeah, I'm a gamer!
I'm a gamer after all!
Nagisa.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Come to think of it, this was a secret.
I see.
I'm not that familiar with the game, but...
I guess that's why it became a battle simulation.
She's a gamer.
Yeah, she's probably a VTuber.
I don't know too much about video games, but it seems to be an effective...
An effective tool?
It seems to be effective also?
Tool?
It seems to be an effective tool for preparing to fight?
In the end, it's a game.
It's a different story if you don't actually move.
If you don't have enough physical strength, you won't be able to fight.
But game skills don't equate to real-life skills necessarily.
For starters, I can't fight if I don't have enough stamina.
Even so, you have enough fighting ability.
I think you've gotten used to being an excellent soldier without any reinforcement.
I'm surprised some of these...
This game isn't so new.
So I'm surprised some of these haven't been patched out.
Proofreading wasn't in the budget.
Please.
Curate.
I will...
I will playtest your games.
Please.
Even though I missed Desperati earlier.
Those skills seem to have done you some good.
Even...
And even without being infected.
You probably had the potential to be a good fighter.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure that's a compliment.
But I don't know if I'm particularly happy about it.
A little more palette swap.
Or other differences between the support maids and the zombie maids.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For me, sometimes it is hard to see them.
Especially like...
Yeah, I do agree though.
Maybe they could have like...
Sort of like...
Maybe a red outline or something.
So you can see them better.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Speaking of questions, I have one for you actually.
Oh.
Kano.
Who are you exactly?
Ohh...
Kano...
Who are you exactly?
Oh, that!
I was a little worried about that too.
I was holding a gun...
But I feel like I'm definitely not a normal person.
Hmm... I was wondering that too.
You have access to guns, so there's no way you're just some regular civilian.
The mystery...
I'm very thankful that you saved me, but I don't think I can fully trust you at this point.
And how were you able to make a vaccine in a modified made calf?
So this is... I know what's happening here.
The... It's supposed to be the E with the little...
The little like... blip!
On top of it, but I think the... it didn't read it, so it made into a question mark.
No special characters, yeah.
E with a hat.
No, it doesn't have a hat.
It has a little...
Blip!
Of all places.
Oh... I wasn't trying to hide anything.
I just didn't feel like there was an appropriate time to explain everything.
Come on!
We have another girl to save!
We can talk about it later.
Oh?
Uh oh...
An ahoge.
Yeah, an ahoge.
The E has an ahoge.
I'm no... Rinka, your suspicions are correct.
I'm no... I am no regular person.
What's more, I'm not entirely unrelated to this pandemic either.
Can you tell me more about it?
Oh...
Elaborate.
What do you mean?
Before that...
First of all, I need to tell you about the pandemic.
I need to tell you about the MADS virus.
To better understand, I'll have to tell you about the MADS virus.
Which is the cause of this pandemic.
This virus was originally a secret research facility of the company Arcana Industries.
Wait, didn't it say the hairpin was Arcana?
The virus was originally developed in secret by a company called Arcana Industries.
MADS...
MADS Nicholson.
It's a very famous company, isn't it?
Yeah.
I heard that they were developing a zombie virus.
Arcana... Aren't they like a globally famous company?
They're the ones who developed some zombie virus?
That's what you mean.
That's right.
I was involved in the research of this virus in the Arcana Industries.
I was a former researcher.
I'm an ex-researcher who was working on the development of the virus at Arcana Industries.
An ex-researcher?
You're that young?
Are you still in junior high or high school?
But you look so young.
How are you a researcher?
I thought you were in middle school, maybe high school.
I'm close to 30 years old.
She's close to 30?
Oh my god.
No way.
You're older than me?
I was talking normally.
I'm sorry.
What is it?
She's in demand.
You're seriously older than me?
I was acting so casual around you.
My apologies.
It's hard to go back, so please do as you did before.
It's also because I didn't explain myself.
Please just keep speaking the way you have been.
It's my fault for not saying anything sooner.
No way.
I didn't know you were involved in the research of the virus.
I'll just ask you this.
That's why you were able to make the vaccine, right?
I never would have thought that you'd be the one in charge of developing the virus.
Did all this happen because of you?
Yes.
I was in charge of the research of the vaccine.
I was the one in charge of the research team.
But there were a lot of things that happened.
The research center was shut down.
There were some issues and I ended up being fired.
Oh my god.
This is some kind of sick retaliation.
This isn't some kind of sick retaliation for being fired, is it?
Rinka-chan!
No, it's not strange to be so suspicious.
At the time of the pandemic, I was visiting the research center to recover my personal belongings.
So how did it get out?
I can see how you think that.
However, when the pandemic started, I was still in the laboratory.
Packing up my belongings.
However, the researchers at the research center were already infected and became zombies.
I hurriedly collected what I needed and left the place.
While I was still there, I started to notice the other researchers turning into zombies.
I grabbed the essentials and made a run for it.
You don't seem to be lying.
Like guns.
Well, you don't seem to be lying.
There is no merit in lying.
My relationship with you is beneficial for the development of vaccines and the eradication of the pandemic.
There's no reason to.
Oh my god.
If I want to stop this pandemic and perfect the vaccine, it's important that we trust each other.
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
My inner thoughts.
I'm perfecting the virus.
I mean the vaccine.
Of course.
I didn't mean...
Friday and slip.
I can't believe Mintz was actually a 5-inch-high researcher of maids the whole time.
What are you talking about?
Why am I only 5 inches?
Plus, you've already gone out of your way to save us.
That's right.
Perfect the virus.
Of course, I understood the danger of that virus.
I think I also have a part of responsibility for what happened.
Obviously, I understood the dangers of that virus.
I take full responsibility for such a horrendous tragedy.
If only I had destroyed that virus after its highly toxic nature was discovered.
It's not your fault!
You didn't do it!
No, I think it is her fault.
I think it is...
Nagisa, I think we're being a little too forgiving here.
I think so.
I think it is 100% her fault.
It's not your fault, Kanon.
No one could have imagined something like this would happen.
I mean, if you're researching...
If you're developing a virus...
Like...
Like this...
Kanon did nothing wrong.
If you call that a sin...
You have to atone for it.
For you...
That is the completion and mass production of the vaccine.
I can't stop you waiting.
I might need to go get some coffee.
If you really feel that it's your fault...
I guess the best way to make up for it would be to complete the vaccine, right?
Yes.
Thank you for your cooperation.
For that, we'll be needing your help.
Of course!
Okay.
Nice.
Let's go get that idol girl.
But first...
I think we need to...
Upgrade a little bit.
Oh, I need the fiber.
Wait!
How did I do that?
It said I had no fiber, right?
Wait, how did I...
Oh, maybe I bought it?
Oh!
Oops.
Oh my gosh.
I get the confirm and the go back buttons wrong.
Did it buy it for me?
Oh.
I guess that's kinda...
I paid for it?
Oh!
I guess that's handy.
And let's also...
We'll do one more?
Nice.
Alright.
Strike.
It buys the needed things if you have the money.
Oh!
That's so handy.
So I don't have to go buy it myself.
Oh, nice.
Only 8 more minutes.
Okay.
Let me go get my coffee real quick.
And then I will...
I already have it made.
So let me go get some...
Or maybe tea.
I don't know.
I'll decide when I'm over there.
And then we'll do the next one.
Give me one second.
I'll be right back.
I accidentally put in way too much creamer!
No!
I accidentally put it way too much creamer!
It always had a nose.
Yeah, I was showing it off.
Did you guys like it?
You guys like my nose.
I got a package.
Hehe.
It's some metal gear goods that I pre-ordered.
Oh, they're so cute!
I got some sticker sheets from someone off Etsy.
And they also had a cute little codec keychain that I got.
It knows where.
Can't you see it?
Can you make your own coffee?
Yeah, I have a French press.
That I use.
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
They're so cute!
Another W for Godot and black coffee.
Oh yeah, it's way too much creamer.
It's basically milk at this point.
I messed up.
Okay, switch over!
And strike!
Oh, only 8 more minutes.
Okay.
Oh, she... Okay, so she's really slow.
She's incredibly slow, but she hits multiple at a time.
She's so slow!
Oh my gosh.
Let's... Let's do a grenade.
Looks like me!
See, but it takes out a good amount of enemies at a time!
Yeah.
Take them out!
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, it's gonna take me a second to get used to this.
How was her melee?
The katana?
Let's do...
Increases close combat by 8%.
Additionally affects some skills.
Let's try adding this.
Cause it's...
Oh wait, what was it?
Oh, left hit.
Right?
But it's kind of...
The...
I'm hoping the attack...
Will like, also help with...
With the...
Cool down, right?
That's another thing we can get, is the cool down.
Let's do a magnum...
Well, actually we'll do the drone.
Trying to get...
Vacuum.
Vacuum...
Oh, we're not getting that vacuum, everybody.
What's her special skill?
Woo!
Wow!
Holy cow!
Oh, optimize.
Here we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Let's do the slash support.
And...
Auto heal.
Cause I need that.
Yeah, the cool down is like so...
It takes so long.
Oh no, no, no!
Trying to get out of here.
Plus one drone.
More drones, please.
I have to survive for eight minutes?
This is gonna suck, you guys.
This is really gonna suck.
I'm not good with the...
What's it called at all?
The sniper.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh!
Take him out!
I thought it would be...
That one.
Ganbare!
Whoa, nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh, there's some virus stuff.
Oh, that's right!
I have no bullets for the support maids.
So, we're on our...
I forgot to make more bullets for the support maids, you guys!
We're on our own!
My CQC seems pretty decent.
Drill.
Drill, drill.
I'm sorry, fellow maid!
Let's see.
More drones.
Nice.
I want that.
Gimme that.
Gimme that!
I'm being greedy.
But it's okay.
I'm being greedy, but it's okay.
I'll heal.
I heal a little bit.
And take him down!
Turn out!
Oh, why does she do it sideways?
No, I was pointing it down!
Oh gosh, I thought, why does she only do it in one direction?
You don't know you're beautiful.
No, no.
That's what makes you beautiful.
Okay, it's not super wide either.
It's only horizontal.
It might also be good to increase defense in certain things too.
Oh gosh, I need all these hearts.
Get out of my way!
Oh gosh!
Special skill turns plus one.
What does that mean?
The idol!
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah!
It does really look like me, doesn't it?
I'd win.
Nice.
One extra charge.
Oh nice.
Let's do the magnetic field.
It's like a good passive to have, I think.
I think it's a good passive to have.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Let's get that vacuum.
Nice.
My maid is a maid of justice.
Yeah.
Nice.
It's horizontal only, but it does go both.
Oh, jeez.
I didn't even realize.
Optimize.
Yeah, there we go.
Nice, nice.
Kill him!
Oh gosh.
Oh no!
Nice.
I just took a little bit of damage there, but...
It's okay.
Or hit the end of the map.
I need more hearts!
Oh no, no, no!
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Took a little bit of damage.
It's okay, I heal eventually.
Oh gosh.
When is my special?
I need more hearts.
Run faster.
I'm trying.
Oh, all of these are new.
Might be good too.
I'm out of special charges.
Let's just...
Wow, nice.
I thought the special would charge over time.
But it doesn't.
It's really sad.
Makes me so sad.
Oh gosh, these guys are stronger.
Okay, there should be more hearts...
up here, you know?
When I killed people before.
When I was a murderer.
Here we are, here we are, here we are.
Yeah, start grabbing these.
Sweet.
Delicious.
Oh, no, the gemmy.
Optimize.
Here we go, here we go.
Here's a lot, here's a lot.
Here's some.
Nice.
There's a sweet gem.
Oh, you!
Where did the gem go?
How much more do I...
Oh my gosh, I still have so much more time.
Guys.
Oh, nice.
I think
the grenade might be good to optimize.
Or have more of.
You, you, you.
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
Oh, don't put you in there.
That's like counterproductive though.
That's not what I want.
Don't go in there.
No!
You know what?
Let's...
We've been using the slash a lot.
So...
I think it's fine.
It's good to have.
Come on, come on, come on.
Yeah!
No!
Down, down, down.
Aim down.
Oh my gosh.
It's not enough.
There it is.
Yippee!
Give me the sweet bucks.
Oh!
I got three!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Just playing Autakai with some cute maid.
Don't kill me.
Nice.
Good.
Just one minute left.
I think we're fine now, honestly.
I think we're more than good, to be honest.
Kinda cleared out a bunch of the...
Big horde.
So...
Sometimes like her shot is so good a damage.
I mean, there's like...
Maybe she can, like, crit stuff and... you know.
Oh!
Oopsie.
Slash!
Get out of my way!
Minto Gaming!
I wish I could convert some of these maids to my side.
They would make such a great army!
The maid army!
Increase healing...
We only have 10 seconds.
We're good.
Blah, blah, blah, blah...
Yippie!
Set her crit rate as 15%.
Ah, okay, okay.
Yay!
What are the odds that the maid that looks like you uses a sniper rifle?
I don't know what to tell...
She doesn't look exactly like me.
You know...
We still S-ranked it.
How much money do we have?
The sprite does.
11,000!
Okay, we're close.
But...
Oh, but...
But, she's like my big sister.
I do kind of like using the katana.
So, I think I might actually... Okay.
I'll use the sniper rifle.
And the sniper rifle!
Is not...
Super easy, but it's not bad.
Is this map even remotely close to Akiba?
The CG scenes are...
Like...
Almost...
Super accurate.
Actually, I think the map is actually kind of accurate too.
You know what?
Yeah.
Let's just upgrade the sniper rifle.
I think we should be good there.
Like this map?
So, if this is...
If this is UDX...
Then, this would be the main street...
Of Akihabara, right?
Oh, I'm kind of blocking some of it.
This would be the main street, Chuo Dori.
This is actually, yeah, pretty accurate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the train station.
Because UDX, you go here.
And train station would be right here.
Right here.
And...
Yeah.
This is basically the size of Akihabara even.
So...
It's pretty accurate.
Oh, bullets!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
You guys saved me.
Thank you.
Workshop.
Buy items.
Let's do five.
Mint enters her mind palace and can view Akihabara as a top-down.
Yeah, just call me Mint Lockholmes.
Defeat all enemies.
Easy.
Let's go.
This game is so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Let's go.
It basically scratches every single one of my itches.
Like being like a visual novel and also...
Being a little edgy and cute and having maids and the vampire survivors part.
Like every bit of it.
I'm just like...
Yeah, I love this.
The sprites are really cute.
They are.
They kind of remind me of phantom breaker.
Does anyone else get that kind of vibe from them?
Toilet paper!
I think that's the fiber.
Oh, there's like more obstacles and stuff now.
It's kind of fun.
Mint.
Mint tante.
Reminds me of Holocure.
Yes.
Well, Holocure is also based off of vampire survivors, right?
So it's...
It's all the same.
A little bit.
Nice.
Let's add more...
I like these guys.
I don't know if they even do that much but...
They work for me.
I like having kind of a barrier.
They do enough.
They do a little bit.
I can see it working.
Optimize!
I didn't realize that my drones could run out.
That's so messed up.
More drones!
The electric drones seem good when they're active.
They're just not active very long.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
It says that they have a cooldown but I didn't realize that they just disappeared altogether.
It's kind of messed up.
Sha!
Nice.
Optimize!
Oops.
I didn't realize I was still on a cooldown.
Sometimes I forget to aim when I'm trying to like find...
Let's see.
Oh, the HP auto-healing.
Let's get that for sure.
Requires a charging period.
Did you do your pulls for Dressina?
Oh, I already did them, Scourge.
Yeah.
I have already done them and I got her after many a pull.
I got her after many a pull but I still got her nonetheless.
Nice.
Yeah, since there's a lot of enemies and we're trying to defeat all of them, having the missiles and grenades and stuff is good, I think.
Yeah.
Rip Oimo.
Screw Oimo.
Wait, what's that little arrow pointing to?
You see that?
What are we heading to?
Oh!
You killed this special thing and I didn't even notice.
Oh my god.
Oh, I wasted that.
My bad.
There we go.
Yeah, screw Oimo.
Okay.
So it does alert you when you have dropped something.
Like that, which is nice.
I always appreciate when games do that.
Thank you, games.
Wish I could get a vacuum.
There's a lot of hearts, but they're all really spread out.
Drone strength.
Oh, here's another one.
You gave her so much gacha luck by cursing her again.
That girl doesn't need any gacha luck at all.
She's like...
Oh my gacha luck is so bad.
She had like 100,000 plus gemis.
What gacha luck do you need?
You're just a whale.
It doesn't matter about your luck.
You're going to get them anyway.
Leave us plebeians alone.
It's basically free to play.
Let the whales do their thing.
But don't take away the luck of us plebes.
Every time you clicked off the stream, she started laughing at your misfortune.
I believe that.
Mike Tyson's ass!
You're eating!
No, girl.
You ate.
Thanks for the five gifts.
The legend.
I really appreciate you always being around.
Thank you.
I'm honored to be visited by a legend.
I wonder how long this one is.
It's to feed all the enemies but they seem very...
It doesn't seem like there are very many guys here.
Not very many people around anymore.
Zombies, are you all dead?
Are you all gone?
Were you all underneath this car?
Is this where you guys are?
Zombies...
Hey, hey.
Don't double.
Don't double team me.
Nice.
Chris is shooting strength by 8%.
I wonder if this one will be good to have too.
Wait.
I mean...
Oh, no.
I'm taking damage.
I'm...
Oh, no.
In my ecchi maid game.
Whatever will I do if I take too much damage?
Don't gang up on me.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Wait, guys.
Oh, no.
I'm gaming too hard.
I can't...
I can't lose clothes.
They need to make the game harder.
So that I can lose more clothes.
Oh, no.
I'm just going to...
The curse of being a pro gamer.
Make the game more difficult.
I guess we'll do the shot support.
It says it affects other stuff too.
I wonder what it affects.
Oh, nice.
Minto when she plays Delta.
Only 30.
Oh, wait.
There's another one.
Come on.
Nice.
Give me more money.
Senran Kagura levels of logic.
Oh, we got a lot of money there, you guys.
I'm just going to start running into them.
All right.
Come on.
Take off my clothes.
Take my clothes.
Okay.
Look how much my health has increased.
It's fine.
How
many more guys are there?
I'm too OP.
I'm too OP, you guys.
I'm actually too OP, I think.
Regen is pretty busted.
Yeah, 100%.
It really is.
Oh, a vacuum.
Oh, sorry.
Don't hurt me.
Regains my special skill power.
You know what?
Let's just use it.
Everything's going to be max at this point.
I'm going to have to...
I have room for other skills.
I don't know.
I haven't decided what I want to get hit yet.
Which is why I'm just maxing everything else out.
This one was like destroy all the enemies, wasn't it?
When does it end?
This level is long.
Yeah, for real.
There's so many enemies.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
They all disappeared.
We did it!
It was 2,197 specifically.
Who knew being a maid was such hard work in serving and fighting?
I know, right?
It's never easy for us.
I lost my clothes, but I'm still S rank, baby.
Let's go to the next one.
I really just want to...
I really just want to find the new girl.
Oh, defeat the boss!
Here we go!
You guys...
Wait.
Before I do that, actually.
I didn't even...
I didn't even recruit any new girls.
Keep from being drama-free.
Tough month, huh?
Wait, what do you mean?
What did I say?
What did I do?
Upgrades?
But I'm saving up for the hairpin.
You know what?
Who cares about the hairpin?
I'm all about that drama, baby.
Level 6.
Level 5.
That should be good.
That should be enough.
Let's strike.
Will you play this game entirely or just kind of off-stream?
I don't know yet.
I think I'll probably play...
You know...
I can probably stream it while I'm in Japan.
This is a perfect game to stream.
I'm trying to find, like, games I can play also in Japan.
Ones that aren't too difficult...
for me to, like...
Because, you know, playing on a laptop...
Playing on a laptop is not always easy.
I really don't know how to play on a laptop.
Hologyre Arc?
I...
Maybe.
I'll probably play that too.
Probably play that while I'm in Japan too.
Everything's a bit cleaner now, huh?
I never expected there to be so many zombies.
Poring, poring.
It's to be expected when you shoot off such flashy fireworks.
I don't think that's all there is to it.
It's very back-saving.
Yeah!
So...
You know, they're just like...
This is the meta.
Why are you playing like this?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So, I don't know.
I'll have to be...
One of those...
In a mood where I'm prepared for people to back-save me.
You know what I mean?
Because usually...
Some days I'm okay with it, and some days I'll be like...
Oh my gosh, I cannot handle it right now.
So...
Yeah, yeah.
But I have been wanting to play it.
I've been like, oh my gosh, I want to do...
Holocure.
I played the one Corona game.
It was so much fun.
And I played it actually off-stream as well too.
I kept playing it.
But...
Overly eager passengers.
Yes!
You must fish in Holocure only.
Fish fishing is the only game.
But...
Corona box?
Yeah!
That one's really fun to play.
We have our own style of play.
And that is okay.
See, that's like a really reasonable way to think about things.
But...
There are also people that just get very passionate.
And I understand.
They're just like, I'm excited.
But, you know, for those kinds of passionate people...
Just play the game yourself.
If you're just like...
I don't like the way these VTubers play in the game.
Then go do it yourself.
Just go play it yourself.
Anyway, okay.
That might not be the only reason.
There were a ton of them though.
Two!
Obyn from Bloons.
Holocure backseaters.
Handle it.
So true.
Have you figured something out?
Miss Rinka?
Oh, it's kind of obvious from the location.
But I guess you'll see once we go inside.
Definitely a VTuber moment.
Stop!
This is the AKB Theater!
No way!
Oh my gosh!
That's so funny!
Have you thought about playing the AquaVN?
Oh, oh!
Personally...
On my personal time, yes.
But on stream?
I don't know.
Maybe.
What's that?
There's a group called AKB48.
And they had their beginnings.
Their humble beginnings.
In the theater.
In the Don Quixote of Akihabara.
And this is specifically that theater.
Because...
Each year, they put a different stripe of tape.
On the...
On the pillars.
So, that's how you can tell.
You didn't do anything wrong?
Oh.
Just election stuff and beast stuff.
What?
We can all come here and be drama free.
Oh!
Yeah.
We don't talk about anything at all.
We all...
I like to...
I like to just hang out and chill.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on.
I only know heavy rotation song.
That's okay.
I like that song too.
I've been to Donkey there many times.
They had a theater.
Yeah!
You have to have a...
You have to apply online for a ticket.
You didn't have to do that in the past.
But now...
I mean, way, way in the past.
But...
It's hard to get tickets for it.
But yeah!
They have a show almost every day.
Made for president!
I was...
Made...
To be number one.
From the footage I have, it appears to be a normal shopping mall.
Am I missing something?
Oh, I see.
I didn't know you, Kanon.
Oh, right.
Of course you don't know Kanon.
This is the battle ground of underground idols.
We are doing a live performance.
This is the holy ground for underground idols.
Underground idols.
There are live performances here every day.
If there was a live performance when the pandemic broke out, it would have been a pretty tragic situation.
It would have been a pretty tragic situation.
If an outbreak were to occur during one of the performances, it would be disastrous, huh?
What?
It's pretty disastrous.
Even if they say underground idols, this place is massive enough to do live performances here.
It would have been pretty dangerous to even know about any group.
Even though we say underground idols, this place is pretty famous.
Anyone who performed here would have had quite the fan base.
Aren't they gonna show the infamous column that impedes the view of like 30% of the seats?
Hahahahaha.
Oh, gosh.
Then when you add in the staff, that's quite a lot of people, don't you think?
Stop spoiling the story.
Sorry!
No doubt.
It's actually funny too, because you can't bring UO's.
UO's are like pen lights that... or not pen lights, but they're like glow sticks that when you break them, they turn super duper bright.
But people in the theater, they've broken them so many times that they had to ban them.
Not because they're so bright, just because they keep breaking them.
Nagisa, look.
Sometimes it is painful to watch a streamer becoming frustrated because she's actively making the game harder on herself without even realizing it, so I can sympathize with helping to an extent.
I get that mentality, for sure.
I think also though, people are so... certain people can be very quick to jump and not allow someone to learn.
You know?
So it's just like... it's kind of a balance.
I think that's why a lot of streamers will have, like... they'll be like, okay I'm ready for back seating now.
They'll kind of... because everybody, you know, especially if someone's... especially if someone is playing a game for the first time, they will not know how to play it.
And so you have to give them a chance to learn how to learn the controls and, you know, it's... I think it's way more rewarding for someone to be playing a game and then, you know, be back in the game.
It's okay to have a hard time.
Yeah, everybody struggles sometimes.
We're all on the struggle bus.
Especially me.
Then chat spams, no help.
They're like, I need help now.
No help.
And sometimes, it's just skill issue.
Why would there be fireworks in this place?
Kanon, this confirms it.
There are a bunch of fireworks missing from the shelves.
The survivors must have used them.
Oh my god, my cat.
I thought I... I didn't see you there, pause!
Oh my gosh, I felt you, but I didn't see you.
Oh my god.
You little plopping girl.
You're so crazy.
She's rolling on the ground.
Let me let my cat out.
She's always hanging out with me.
I love her.
I love you little girl.
You're so stinky.
So cute.
What are you doing?
You're stretching.
You're being cute, girl.
You're so crazy.
You're a crazy girl.
You know that?
You're crazy.
Okay, I'll be right back.
One month without pies.
Don't remind me.
Okay, please.
I'll be right back.
Let me let her out.
It's funny because when I stream with Po...
Butaro.
When I stream with Butaro, he...
He...
He hates... As soon as I start streaming, he wants out of my room.
But with Paz, she likes to hang around.
Sorry.
I obviously combined Paz and Butaro together.
You know?
He's stream shy.
Yeah.
I have two cats, if nobody knows.
If you don't know.
I have Paz.
I just got her recently.
And then I have Butaro.
He's my little guy.
I, too, combine my cats all the time.
Yeah.
Butaro.
Basically, might as well be him.
Any signs of the survivors?
Both are allegedly quite stinky.
Watch out, Nagisa!
Cute.
Isn't that Maidle 5's Arisa?
Maidle 5?
Super cute!
Remember what I said?
They're one of those popular underground idol groups.
Everyone's dressed in maid dresses and it's super cute!
Arisa-chan was the most popular out of the group, but to think she'd end up zombified like this...
Maybe she was a survivor.
I love my Chika idols.
I love my Chika idols zombified.
Maybe we didn't make it on time.
No, wait.
She's a subject, but doesn't seem like she's completely zombified yet.
No, hold on a sec.
It looks like she hasn't fully transformed yet.
So... wanted I was the same as her?
So she's the same as us!
Oh my god.
The maid... the maid buff.
Maid buff!
It appears so.
It may be that she's also...
Oh, she's always carried... Oh, it may be that she's always carried the antibodies.
There's also a chance that she might have developed them.
Who's better?
Sesshomaru or Sephiroth?
What the hell?
I'm not really a fan of either of them.
That doesn't matter now.
We still have a chance to save her, so we should hurry it up.
That's right.
Let's go, Rinko-chan!
An obstacle.
Got it.
Understood.
What?
Stop throwing it that way.
Nice.
Let's do a slash.
This game has such awesome music.
Why is it so funny?
I want to get closer to the stage.
I'm gonna go cheer on Mayoshi!
I like the miniature missiles too.
I think they're pretty good.
Toilet paper!
I haven't needed things like the shields yet, so...
Oh, hello Otaku-chan!
I see a maid there, but...
It's like a maze in here.
Being able to get over to the...
Nice.
Oh, the stage!
Oh, you don't want to get trapped in here.
It's pretty bad.
You don't want to get trapped in here.
Time to update my wish list.
It is fine though, right?
Most of the grenades she can throw across the barriers and stuff.
I don't know.
I hope it's so good.
Toilet paper!
Oh my god.
They're all funneling through here.
Nice!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Wow!
Get out of my face.
Nice!
Ah!
This is such a small map.
I know, right?
Yeah, I can see it becoming bad too.
Oh!
Oh, this is invisibility!
This is the invisibility...
Oh, well...
It doesn't last very long and they can still see me, I think!
Nice!
Where's the boss?
Where's she at?
I think we have to go through it a little bit and then we get to her, right?
Oh, I'm getting trapped again.
Nice, nice.
Die, zombie!
Nice.
Give me money!
I don't know why do I need money in the apocalypse.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh, the pillars!
Let's do the incendiary grenade.
A nice passive one.
Oops.
I don't even know what I just attacked.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
Oh, oh
gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Don't get...
The missiles are so good.
Holy moly.
This is the pillar.
Let's get some support drones.
If we want to talk meta, the drone meta, baby.
This is a nice spot to be in, maybe.
Look at all that bla...
Oh my god, there's so many girls up there!
Oh, flamethrowers!
There's two of them.
Yeah!
Drone meta is real.
Take them out!
I'm so effective.
There's no one else to kill.
Oh, nice.
The drones should get cg art too.
So true.
Oop, I was not even... my bad.
I don't... because I don't like... you know, at least with the stage, I can have like a...
Oh gosh.
At least with the stage, I can have like a wall.
Nice.
I don't know.
Here we go.
I like this area way better.
Because also the chairs kind of block them too.
This ends up being a pretty decent spot, I'd say.
Oh my gosh, look at all of them fuddling through here.
Come on, babies!
Oh no!
No, no, no!
Oh no, no, no!
I heal so fast though, I don't know why I'm even worried about taking damage.
I'd have to be like super... super tackled to be in a bad spot, you know?
Just stand still.
Yeah, pretty much.
And the missiles are OP, for real.
Oh!
Oh, she's here!
She's here!
Oh, there she is!
Oh my god, stop!
She's the cutest ever!
Stop!
She's hopping at me!
Oh my god, she's perfect!
Oh!
I think almost all... Oh, got it.
Oh, got it.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh no, does that mean all of the bosses are gonna have the same fighting style?
I wonder.
Can you recruit her?
Yeah, baby!
That's what we're gonna do!
She's so cute.
I need her on my team.
I need her.
This game is very obviously not for the gameplay, though.
Because there's so much time in between her, like... between her doing this attack, you know?
Oh no, the little tiny missile!
Where did she go?
There she is.
She's like a Jiangshi.
I know!
It's so cute!
Yippee!
I saw your super chat.
What did you ask?
I always hated mint-flavored things.
Because of you, I gave it another chance and I actually like it now.
Yippee!
Time to cure everybody.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
I brought Arisa-chan with me.
Time to cure.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
We got Arisa!
Lay her down here, please.
I'll start the procedure immediately.
I was in the same state as this girl.
When I think about it, I really think that being alive was a miracle.
I was in a similar state to her, right?
Thinking about it logically, it's a miracle that I was able to come to my senses.
I'm ready to dork it.
It'll all work out.
Kanon knows what she's doing.
You should know better than anyone.
Right, Rinka?
Yeah, you're right.
I'll do my best.
Let's start right away.
Let's pray for the best.
I'll begin the procedure.
The procedure should be in quotes.
Oh boy.
Let's pray for the best.
Oh, she's perfect!
I'll start the procedure.
Stop!
She's perfect!
Oh god!
Depart, depart, depart.
Oh god, she's so perfect!
No, don't do it!
Don't change her!
I love her as she is!
Oh god, she's so cute!
Oh no!
She's so my type!
It hurts!
HAHAHA.
Giyu giyu giyu giyu.
Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko.
Everybody let's shuko together!
Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko Shuko...
OMG she is so cute!
She is so blue!
Her color palette is perfect the way it is.
Madison!
Shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou...
Medicine!
It's medicine, you guys.
This is a medicinal procedure.
I can't keep defending my Yoshi like this.
This is a medical procedure!
Shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou...
Shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou.
Shikou!
Shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou!
Shikou, shikou!
Shikou, shikou, shikou!
Medicine!
I like the way we just splatter it on her.
She's gonna cure!
Oh she's so cute!
Shikou, shikou, shikou, shikou...
That's right!
There's why you're the best boss!
Shuko!
Get cured!
Where'd the sharp teeth go?
I know, it's such a downgrade, isn't it?
Don't shuko too hard.
You might damage the vaccine bottle.
Sometimes I rip the skin.
Use medicine!
You know what's a really good part?
It's right here.
This right here.
What is this expression?
I wish I only had the tiny parts of Arisa.
Shuko!
In the end we were only able to save Arisa, huh?
Even though there were others there...
We became zombies.
I had no choice.
I thought there might be more survivors but it seems they were all turned into zombies.
You don't need to worry about it.
Rather, you should be happy that we got me out.
It was a triumph of a digital art.
Please don't blame yourselves.
In fact, we should be happy that we were able to save Ms. Arisa.
So, Arisa also had the antibodies.
And because of them, she was able to prolong the zombification process compared to the average victim.
Wow, it seems like... what are the odds that three people in Akihabara all have the antibodies?
Like, what are the odds?
Anime.
I wonder how many people out there have these antibodies.
Yeah, me too!
I've been wondering about that!
Right!
When you think of it, shouldn't there be more people?
Only having the three of us seems like too few.
All of these digital media.
Made armor real.
But the odds are pretty low.
Oh, I can't be certain, but the odds are pretty low.
It'd be something like 1 in 10,000 or 1 in 100,000.
I'd win.
Give me them gotcha rates.
Ms. Arisa's existence is like a miracle.
It's like a miracle.
Sorry.
Ms. Nagisa, Ms. Rinka, and Ms. Arisa.
The odds of the three of you were in the same area during a pandemic like this is nothing short of a miracle.
That's right.
Miracle.
I am the chosen one in this world!
Oh no, she's perfect!
Yes, it is indeed a miracle.
I was one of the chosen ones after all!
Oh my god.
I am the chosen one!
She's perfect.
Thank you for the gift!
Fifty Gifted Wandering Taco, thank you!
Okay, fine, I will now buy this game.
You seem to know my name.
As expected, I am the chosen one in this world.
Oh, it appears you know my name.
Proof that I am indeed one of the chosen few.
You guys saved me, didn't you?
I am grateful.
No matter how chosen you are, you are still dead.
You peasants rescued me, correct?
Thank you for the gift!
I offer you my thanks.
Though I am a child of destiny, even I have my limits and would have died without your assistance.
Zombies came rushing in during the live show.
It is true that I sympathize with you.
In a blink of an eye, even my followers became zombies.
Take off!
Take off the gift!
I hope work wasn't too hard for you.
She just called us peasants.
Yeah.
And I wish she'd do it again.
During our live, the zombies swarmed in.
It was utter pandemonium.
Our worshippers succumbed to the virus in mere seconds.
I was able to hide myself from a few of my followers.
But the followers who were ruled by fear...
Yes, my master!
...went away one by one.
Welcome back, Kuroneko.
At first, I was able to hide among several loyal followers.
But soon, they could no longer resist their fear.
And one after the other, ran away.
Oh, doesn't sound very loyal at all.
They ran away?
Like, leaving you all alone?
Shunin made...
Mint, what have you unleashed?
What a humble person.
I must dedicate my life.
I'm sure in their minds, it was a tactical retreat.
Though most of them had lost the capacity for rational thought.
I have no intention of attacking them.
If I say I didn't feel any fear, that would be a lie.
Her voice sounds kind of like...
Tsukino Mito.
I cannot condemn those brave young men and women.
For even I felt an ounce of fear seep into my bones.
My Oshii is a simp like me, for real, for real.
So which maid is so far the cutest besides you?
Do you have to ask?
So, let me get this straight.
You were the one that shot off the fireworks, right?
You guys hear it, right?
So funny.
That is correct.
Umma!
I had exhausted all of the resources and was left no choice.
But in the end, it ended up being a beacon for those cursed beings.
In the end, I was surrounded, and I understood the end.
But now that I have survived, there is no problem at all.
I thought I had met my end when they surrounded me.
But the fact that I am here now speaks a great deal.
Umma!
You are quite...
You seem to be a rather strange individual.
More like she is delusional.
Thank
you!
How do I say your name?
As...
Afic?
Asfix?
These maids are pretty cute, but Mint is still the cutest one.
Stop it!
Stop.
Stop it.
You really are unique, aren't you, Arisa?
That's what makes you adorable.
You must be shocked, aren't you?
You lost a friend from the same idol group.
Oh.
I bet it was a major shock for you, though.
I mean, you lost all your friends who were in the same idol group, right?
Unfortunately, I don't think so.
We were friends who swore to save the world through singing.
I shall never forget the fallen.
For they were my comrades.
And arms were yours bent on saving the world through song.
But...
What are you sad about?
I have accepted their souls.
People died, Arisa.
People died.
It's so tragic that she has brain damage now, right?
But there's nothing to be saddened about.
Their souls still live on within me.
You're strong, Arisa-chan.
You're strong, Arisa.
Mm-hmm.
It's only natural that you're chosen to save the world.
Hehe, that I am.
That's why I'm the child of destiny who will one day save this planet.
But...
Hold it.
I just realized.
Oh?
Are you...
Zombie Hunters?
Are there no blonde-haired ninjas among your friends?
What?
You two are Zombie Hunters, correct?
Are you not working with a blonde-haired ninja?
What?
What are you talking about?
Come again?
You're that ninja.
You're talking about that kind of thing, aren't you?
Must be another one of her delusions.
No!
Where there's a zombie, there's her!
She's the one who saves people from zombies!
There's a lady who appears when zombies approach!
A true savior for humanity!
Naruto!
She saved you, but then left you to die, apparently.
She saved my life, but immediately vanished without stating her name.
Well, after that, I was surrounded by zombies again, and I had no other choice but to hide.
Shortly after, I was cornered once again.
Leading me to go into hiding.
I heard that saving people is not your goal.
Believe it.
If that's the case, you won't leave survivors behind, will you?
Yeah, true.
Perhaps her motives aren't to save people.
I mean, if she was trying to do that, she would have gotten you to safety, right?
I wonder...
A blonde ninja...
It might be the result of the situation.
We can't say that for certain.
It's difficult to carry someone to safety while moving.
She might have just done what she was capable of at the time.
Hmm, something seems off...
But that's
awesome!
There's someone else, other than us, that's fighting the zombies!
Besides, the way I heard about Arisa-chan, she's a very strong person.
If we have the same goal, we can become friends, right?
And hearing your story, Arisa, she seems to be an incredible fighter.
Maybe we can befriend her since we have similar goals!
Doki?
Doki's not a ninja.
Doki ninja outfit win.
She's a western ninja.
Would cowboys be considered western ninjas, maybe?
Yet.
Putting our motives aside for one second, the fact that she can fight zombies might mean she's a normal human either.
Maybe.
No, they're western samurai.
Oh, you're right, you're right, you're right, they're western samurai.
True, true, true.
A person with antibodies.
She might even be like you, Miss Nagisa.
Never having undergone transformation.
And perhaps it's as Miss Nagisa said, she might actually cooperate with us.
What should we do, Nagisa?
What should we do?
There's no need to ask.
What's the plan, Nagisa?
Heh, who am I kidding?
I already know your answer.
Please!
I don't want to be a grammar police, but please!
Of course, I'll go look for her.
Of course, we're gonna go look for her.
But what's that saying?
The more the merrier?
Oh, you're going to go look for that blonde ninja?
You are answer.
Of course, I'll go with you.
You are answer!
So it shall be then.
Allow me to join you on the search for the blonde haired ninja.
What?
No need to worry.
I'll choose again.
You are the chosen one.
I won't let you go like a zombie anymore.
Do not fret, my comrades.
I am the chosen one.
I will never fall to those zombie scum.
Scum.
Arisa Hika... Hikami.
Oh, sorry.
I thought it was like one word.
Arisa Hikami.
Nice.
Headband A?
What's headband A mean?
She's so cute.
Let me touch her.
Are you interested in my face?
Yeah.
Idols are not lame.
Juni Minto for Halloween special win.
Are you interested in my face?
Idols are not lame.
Yeah.
If you touch me until you feel like it.
No.
Wait, I can touch your feet.
What?
Touching the feet does nothing?
Are you interested in my face?
Idols are not lame.
No.
No reaction to the feet.
You know what?
It's to make it fair, you guys.
It's to make it fair.
Because we can't touch their feet.
It would be unfair if she reacted to her feet and we wouldn't be able to touch any other feet.
You know?
Hm?
Well, guys.
I have another collab in about an hour.
So I think that's where we're gonna leave it off here.
Just gonna save just in case.
Game saved.
We got three girls.
Who was...
Who also...
How do I get to the main menu?
There's even...
There's a lot of sub stores too.
Oh, there's a lot of sub stores.
Wow.
The harem is taking shape.
And we have a headband we can buy now.
How much is it?
Oh, gosh.
Titan silver.
So I have enough Titan silver.
I just need...
I need the...
The money.
Oh, I'm close to 20,000 though.
I'm close, actually.
Increases attack.
Increases power and point growth.
Houdou deuxime victorie dans le point de sortie Mm...
But yeah, this has been so much fun!
This has been so much fun.
Oh, my gosh.
I just noticed that Nagisa has like a half...
A half...
Nakada-kun
Everybody's so cute!
All of them are so cute!
Nakada-kun
Thank you for the streaming, though.
Thank you!
Thanks guys for hanging out with me, allowing me to play this silly little, uh, little, um, ecchi game about maids and zombies.
My favorite things ever.
How do I go back to the main menu?
No, no, no.
Back, back, back, back.
Help!
Oh, return the title!
There we go.
Let's see, who else do we have?
Oh, there's our ninja!
And there's Onesa.
Holy...
There's a ghost maid and beast tamer?
What?
No way!
Wow.
Wait, she uses a chainsaw!
She's even more perfect!
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Oh gosh, I can't wait to play as her!
Oh gosh, I can't wait to play as her.
Um...
This song makes me just wanna headbang, you know?
She packs a chainsaw!
Oh, and like, the shine.
Oh my gosh, so awesome!
Best character.
Look at... I think they need to get new uniforms.
They're about to bust out of these.
But also, Bustin' makes me feel good.
Anyways guys, thanks for Maid of the Dead!
We'll probably continue it eventually.
I don't know when.
Probably sometime in Japan, you know?
And yeah, I'm gonna go get some food before the next collab.
In the pinned message, you'll see that I'm collabing with Berry and Ashton.
Later on, we'll be being silly, goofy... Disney adults.
So...
Great stream, Minto!
Thank you!
And um...
Yeah!
I'm gonna go get some stuff for my throat, even.
Gonna drink some throat tea.
And get some dinner.
I suggest you guys do the same.
And I'll see you guys later!
Thank you so much for watching me!
I know it was really, really early.
Different from my time, usually.
But I appreciate you watching and hanging out with me today!
Thank you!
I'll see you guys later!
Thank you, Ashton!
Thank you...
Thank you, Minto!
See you later!
Bye bye!
See you guys later!